avant de commencer
la séance de questions au Gouvernement
je voudrais
prononcer quelques mots
notre pays à la chance de pouvoir
compter sur des citoyens qui s'engagent
pour servir
protéger et soigner les autres
aucun ne devrait avoir le fer au péril
de sa vie
dimanche trois jeunes policiers sont
morts dans un terrible accident dans le
Nord
lundi un agent de la Direction
interdépartementale des routes
atlantiques a perdu la vie dans un autre
accident en Charente-Maritime
ce matin une infirmière du CHU de Reims
est décédé à la suite du nourrible
agression
au nom de la représentation nationale je
vous demande de bien vouloir observer
une minute de silence en hommage aux
victimes et en soutien à ceux qui les
aimaient
exprimons également ensemble notre
reconnaissance à tous les agents du
service public qui œuvrent au quotidien
avec un dévouement exemplaire au service
des citoyens et de l'intérêt général
je vous remercie
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement
la première d'entre elles va être posée
par Monsieur Madame la première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je veux tout
d'abord vous remercier madame la
Présidente d'avoir rendu cet hommage
nous avons appris ce matin avec une
grande tristesse le décès de
l'infirmière violemment agressé hier au
CHU de Rennes
ce drame s'ajoute de race pardon
excusez-moi ce drame s'ajoute à ceux qui
ont brutalement frappé les agents du
service public ces derniers jours la
mort de trois jeunes policiers dimanche
qui accompagnaient une victime à
l'hôpital et ont été percutées par un
chauffard et ce lundi c'est un agent de
la direction inter départementale des
routes atlantiques qui a été
mortellement blessé alors qu'il
intervenait pour la mise en sécurité
d'un véhicule je veux également avoir
une pensée pour leurs collègues blessés
et encore hospitalisés aux familles aux
proches et aux collègues des victimes je
veux dire ma solidarité la solidarité de
mon gouv ernement comme l'ont fait les
ministres qui se sont rendus sur les
lieux de ces drames
mesdames et messieurs les députés
s'engager pour nos services publics
servir les autres protéger soigner
éduquer ce sont des missions qui
honorent celles et ceux qui les exercent
au quotidien
leur engagement fait la force de notre
pays il fait notre cohésion et nous
rassemble à tous les agents du service
public je veux redire mon émotion et mon
soutien je veux assurer chacune et
chacun de la reconnaissance de la Nation
de la reconnaissance des Français qui
savent leur sens du service et leur
dévouement je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
donc là première question va être posée
par Monsieur Xavier Albertini pour le
groupe horizon
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
après la disparition tragique dimanche
matin de trois policiers dans le cas de
leur mission de service public hier
après-midi au CHU de Reims un
déséquilibré agresser une infirmière une
secrétaire médicale nous avons appris ce
matin le décès de Karen infirmière
âgé de 38 ans à cet instant j'ai une
pensée sincère pour cette femme qui
exerçait un merveilleux métier tourné
vers l'autre et je présente mon nom et
au nom du groupe horizon apparenté et je
suis sûr de l'ensemble de mes collègues
ma compassion et mes sincères
condoléances à sa famille à ses proches
à ses collègues et à toute la communauté
des soignants de ce pays
nous avons naturellement une pensée pour
la seconde victime dont les jours ne
sont heureusement plus en danger hier au
CHU de Reims un homme muni d'un couteau
venant de l'extérieur de l'établissement
aéré aéré dans les services à pénétrer
dans un vestiaire à commis un acte
irréparable serait terrible drame est
une nouvelle fois en lumière la
situation difficile de nos soignants
dans les hôpitaux et les cabinets
médicaux ne soignons sont trop souvent
agressés verbalement mais aussi
physiquement cette violence inacceptable
a d'ailleurs augmenté de 23% entre 2021
et 2022 être soignant c'était dès
l'autre prendre soin de l'autre
aujourd'hui cette communauté est à bout
elle est la cible trop souvent de
frustration individuelle non maîtrisée
de certains passions de certains
patients et plus largement de non
respect de l'autre cette terrible
agression met aussi en lumière la
difficile gestion de maladies et de
malades atteintes de troubles
psychiatriques l'homme gardait à lui
était placé sous curatelle renforcé et
au titre de violence aggravée en 2022
avait été déclaré irresponsablement des
faits près d'un an après les mesures de
sûreté le concernant n'étaient toujours
pas prises hier et nous savons qu'il
était en rupture de complètement
médicaux ma question s'adresse donc un
monsieur le ministre la santé de la
prévention monsieur le ministre une
infirmière est Mortière à Reims cette
tragédie mettant lumière les difficultés
du travail de nos soignants quelle
mesure comptez-vous prendre et mettre en
œuvre dès à présent en lien avec les
travaux lancers en janvier dernier par
notre par votre collègue madame Firmin
le Baudeau afin de rétablir chez les
professionnels la sérénité qui leur est
dû et leur permettre de se mobiliser
uniquement sur leur vocation première
soigner et prendre soin des autres je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la Santé de
la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur député
Albertini cette agression mortelle qui a
lieu qui a eu lieu hier à Reims nous
anéantit tous de personnels hospitaliers
une infirmière une secrétaire médicale
ont été violemment agressés dans
l'exercice de leur fonction et
l'infirmière Karen 38 ans est décédé des
suites de ses blessures
ma pensée comme toute cette assemblée va
bien sûr d'abord à la victime qui se bat
encore sa famille à leurs proches nos
équipes qui sont intervenus sur place
immédiatement les équipes du Samu les
chirurgiens anesthésistes et
d'opératoires qui sont intervenus le
plus vite possible pour essayer de
sauver de sauver Karen
le temps est d'abord bien entendu au
recueillement
cette agression nous fait nous réfléchir
et penser tous à au risque qu'il y a
dans ces métiers qui sont au contact de
la population on ne peut pas imaginer un
hôpital entièrement fermé l'hôpital et
le lieu où on accède lorsqu'on est
malade lorsqu'on est en difficulté ce
qui rend extrêmement difficile le
travail qui a été entrepris et que
j'avais confié que j'ai confié à Agnès
Firma le Baudot sur la sécurité des
soignants et les violences dont nous
attendons les résultats dans les
semaines qui viennent pour autant avant
même d'attendre ces résultats j'ai
décidé de réunir jeudi matin les
organisations syndicales les
représentants des professionnels pour
que on accélère et qu'on voit tout de
suite s'il y a des solutions possibles
pour améliorer cette sécurité je vous
remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur David Guiraud
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente trois jeunes
policiers du commissariat de Roubaix
sont décédés ce dimanche dans l'exercice
de leur fonction aux familles aux
proches et aux collègues je veux redire
la peine les représentants de la nation
et leur présenter nos condoléances
attristées et témoignés de notre
reconnaissance
c'est le moment d'unités sont rares
mais ils sont précieux
rares et précieux souvent nous sommes en
désaccord et c'est normal et parfois
votre silence est aussi incompréhensible
qu'un juste les salariés de Vertbaudet
en sont l'exemple les Verbaudet ce sont
ces femmes mal payées au SMIC certaines
ont 30 ans de bons et loyaux services et
elles ne connaissent aucune augmentation
de salaire les prix augmentent elles
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs factures
et à nourrir les leurres alors elles
sont rentrées en grève pour se faire
entendre et la semaine dernière le
délégué syndical de ces femmes a été
enlevé devant ses enfants par des
individus se présentant comme policier
qui l'ont humilié battu volés et menacé
de mort et qui a réagi où est le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui qui
communique souvent pas même un tweet
pour dire qu'il va assurer la protection
de cet homme où est le ministre de
l'économie pour dire que ces femmes sont
trop précaires pour nourrir leurs
familles et que puisque l'entreprise va
bien et que le patron gagne 60 000 euros
par mois alors il peut bien répondre à
la demande d'augmentation de 150 euros
net pour ces femmes où est la secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes pourquoi ne
s'indignent-elles pas de cette direction
qui a multiplié publiquement les
déclarations sexistes les plus
scandaleuses et le porte-parole du
gouvernement alors plutôt que de mentir
et ont aimant ce matin sur les propos de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est passé les
soutenir devrait plutôt s'excuser puis
dépenser son énergie quelques secondes
pour porter la parole des salariés et
convoqué à son bureau le patron de
Verbaudet citoyen accepté pas d'acheter
une marque qui brutalise les femmes
boycotter Vertbaudet parfois collègues
nous partageons nos peines nos joies
communes alors cette fois juste cette
fois partager notre colère gloire au
grévistes de Vertbaudet
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Guillaume nous interrogez sur la
situation au sein de l'entreprise
Vertbaudet peut-être qu'il est utile
avant d'en venir à la situation présente
de rappeler ce qui s'est passé dans les
dernières semaines un conflit social
c'est noué à l'occasion de négociations
annuelles début mars au sein de cette
entreprise en tout cas de cet
établissement situé dans le nord de la
France une grève a été déclenchée le 20
mars à la fin du mois de mars un accord
a été signé par deux organisations
syndicales enfin s'ouvrières et la
CFE-CGC qui elle de représente 63% des
salariés selon le résultat des dernières
consultations internes et donc cet
accord est majoritaire la CGT n'a pas
accepté cet accord je le constate sans
porter du jugement et a ouvert un
mouvement de grève qui aujourd'hui
concerne 70 à 80 salariés sur les 330 à
340 salariés du site
cette accord ce conflit a entraîné une
médiation de la Direction Départementale
de l'emploi de l'économie du travail et
la solidarité qui s'est traduit à
l'issue de cette médiation par
l'engagement de l'entreprise formaliser
le 1er mai dernier d'embaucher en
contrat durée déterminée indéterminée 30
des intérimaires précédents et donc de
déprécariser un certain nombre de
personnel le conflit dure encore à la
demande du député Fabien Roussel qui m'a
alerté il vient maintenant une dizaine
de jours sur cette situation mes
services mon cabinet en faciliter la
mise en contact de la direction générale
et de la direction nationale de la CGT
des contacts informel ont eu lieu au
cours de la semaine dernière et une
réunion s'est tenue hier matin en la
mairie de Marquette-lez-Lille avec la
direction générale de l'entreprise avec
les représentants représentants
syndicaux signataires et non signataires
de l'accord intervenir fin mars de
nouvelles propositions étaient faites
notamment d'avancer la date des NAO le
fait de pouvoir alléger et même renoncer
à une partie des sanctions envisagées
contre certains salariés qui étaient sur
les piquets de grève à nouveau ces
propositions étaient rejetées par la CGT
nous continuerons comme nous le faisons
depuis le début à faciliter toutes les
médiations dans le respect du droit
social et du dialogue social merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur
Eric Girardin pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé et de la prévention
chers collègues monsieur le ministre de
la Santé nous étions ensemble hier soir
dans ma circonscription aux côtés du
président du conseil de surveillance du
centre hospitalier universitaire de
Reims maire de Reims Monsieur Arnaud
Robinet et de Madame la Directrice du
CHU en présence des autorités
judiciaires et de toute la communauté
médicale sous le choc suite à la
dramatique agression d'une infirmière et
d'une secrétaire médicale qui ont été
sauvagement poignardées par un
déséquilibré dans ce contexte tragique
vous avez témoigné votre soutien aux
victimes et plus largement à l'ensemble
des personnels hospitaliers qui doivent
faire face à ces menaces quotidiennes
vous avez rappelé la vitesse
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
pour appréhender le suspect mais aussi
et surtout la vitesse avec laquelle les
victimes de cette attaque ont été prises
en charge par leurs collègues
malheureusement malgré d'importants
efforts nous apprenions ce matin le
décès de cette infirmière 36 ans tandis
que sa collègue reste dans un état grave
à cet instant nous adressons notre
compassion notre soutien et nos
condoléances à la famille aux proches à
l'ensemble des personnels du CHU et à la
grande famille du soin
[Applaudissements]
cet événement dramatique corrobore les
chiffres de l'Observatoire national des
violences en milieu de santé qui
décomptaient en 2021 19 328 cas de
violence c'est-à-dire d'atteinte aux
personnes et aux biens chaque jour près
de 30 infirmières et infirmiers font
l'objet d'agression sur le territoire
national ces agressions cette haine la
France ne peut pas l'accepter et je
souhaite rappeler ici devant la
représentation nationale le soutien
inconditionnel de la République à nos
soignants qui œuvrent quotidiennement
pour assurer les soins des Français
sauvant des vies chaque jour
monsieur le ministre dans ce contexte
terrible comment pouvons-nous renforcer
notre arsenal de prévention au quotidien
pour faire en sorte que plus jamais de
tel drame ne se produisent je vous
remercie beaucoup
mes collègues la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la Santé de
la prévention
députés monsieur le député Gérardin je
vous remercie de souligner et je vais le
faire également la célérité
d'intervention de la police hier pour
maîtriser le l'agresseur également la
célérité de la justice et du procureur
pour se saisir de cette affaire et
mettre le suspect l'auteur en garde à
vue rapidement
par un hasard malheureux j'ai inauguré
ce matin le salon sante expo malheureux
parce que le président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France qui organise ce
salon et également le maire de Reims
donc nous sommes retrouvés ce matin dans
les situations dramatiques bien sûr
cette agression était dans toutes les
têtes des soignants qui étaient présents
et avec son accord j'ai demandé une
minute de silence plutôt que d'inaugurer
ce salon de façon traditionnelle j'ai
d'ailleurs annoncé aussi une minute de
silence demain midi dans tous les
hôpitaux de France en mémoire de Karen
les soignants je vous rejoins sont
les soignants sont trop souvent victimes
de violence injustement qualifié
d'incivilité il n'y a pas de petites
violence qu'elle soit par geste verbale
également photographique par tweet
nous ne devons jamais banaliser la
violence et je discutais encore ce matin
avec des soignants sur le salon et
soyons beaucoup trop tendance à
banaliser cette violence verbale ou ses
gestes qui leur sont adressés c'est
inacceptable ça doit rester inacceptable
et je suis certain que dans cette
émission vous condamnerez tous cette
banalisation de la violence quelle
qu'elle soit et d'où qu'elle vienne nous
allons mettre en place le plus
rapidement possible des mesures
complémentaires même si beaucoup de
choses sont faites mais je tiens en
conclusion à rappeler encore une fois la
diligence de l'ensemble des services
publics police justice service de santé
qui ont malheureusement pas pu éviter le
pire mais qui ont moins permis de sauver
une des deux victimes je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame evaas pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique hier Jean Pisani ferry et
selmafouz ont remis à la première
ministre un rapport établi à sa demande
qui confirme à bien des égards les
analyses des écologistes oui il faut
accélérer l'action pour le climat le
rythme actuel de baisse des émissions
est très insuffisante oui les plus
riches ont une responsabilité plus
grande dans le dérèglement climatique
leur empreinte carbone et trois fois
supérieure à celle des 10% les plus
modestes et en regard le changement
climatique impacte plus durement les
plus pauvres oui il faut augmenter
massivement le financement public de la
transition écologique entre 25 et 34
milliards par an à horizon 2030 dont 10
à 14 milliards pour la seule rénovation
thermique des logements et enfin oui il
faut financer ses dépenses
exceptionnelles par un prélèvement
exceptionnel Jean Pisani ferry propose
un impôt sur le patrimoine financier des
10% les plus aisés s'attaquer aux niches
fiscales néfastes au climat est
absolument nécessaire mais vous suffira
pas alors depuis quelques jours vous
avez visiblement lancé une énième
opération de communication autour de la
question climatique vous semblez donc
enfin ouvrir les yeux sur les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
mais vous comprendrez qu'après 6 ans de
communication sur l'écologie jamais
suivi de politique à la hauteur des
enjeux et alors que vous parcourez les
plateaux pour juste annoncer que vous
allez faire des annonces nous attendions
des engagements concrets et ce d'autant
que Bruno Le Maire a déjà annoncé ce
matin qu'il ne suivrait pas les
recommandations du rappeur qui signifie
alors ma question sera simple quand
allez-vous enfin arrêter la
communication et vous décidez à écouter
des économistes qui vous conseillent il
faut investir massivement dans la
transition écologique supprimer les
niches fiscales pour le climat et
réguler les comportements les plus
émetteurs à commencer par ceux des plus
riches
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
SAS
vous évoquez le rapport Pisani ferrique
a été remis hier et donc si je comprends
bien vous faites une lecture qui
consiste à le résumer à une proposition
au lieu d'insister sur toutes ces
dimensions ce rapport d'abord ce rapport
d'abord il a été réalisé à la demande du
gouvernement pour chiffrer le coût de la
transition écologique il s'inscrit dans
le chantier plus large de la
planification confié et piloté par la
première ministre et il est en termes de
calendrier présentez le jour où la
perspective d'aller construire une
planification écologique pour arriver
aux 270 millions de tonnes d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en 2030 en
respectant nos engagements climatiques a
été présenté devant le CNTE ce qui est
une première
dans ce contexte il explique qu'il y a
un besoin de financement et il identifie
trois pistes
d'abord faire en sorte de réorienter des
dépenses budgétaires en faisant en sorte
que le brin finance le vert ensuite
expliqué que on ne peut pas traiter la
question de la dette pour faire en sorte
de tenir nos engagements climatiques en
particulier en matière de rénovation de
la même manière qu'on regarde les
dépenses publiques de manière plus
classique et enfin il dit que la
question de la fiscalité peut s'inviter
dans le débat mais ce que je souhaite
avant toute chose c'est vous demander
d'arrêter le petit jeu qui consiste à
répéter de manière systématique des
éléments de langage qui tournent à vide
et qui sont faux
depuis que les écologistes
depuis que les écologistes ne sont plus
en responsabilité et je sais que vous en
souffrez le rythme de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
doubler dans ce pays c'est une réalité
si on avait écouté certains d'entre vous
c'est la filière nucléaire et la
capacité à produire de l'économie
carbonée que nous aurions arrêté
heureusement que nous n'avons pas suivi
les plus radicaux et heureusement
aujourd'hui que dans la manière dont on
construit une planification écologique
on le fait en tenant compte et de
l'économie et du social sortez de
l'idéologie regardez ce que nous
proposons les solutions sont de notre
côté merci beaucoup monsieur minet
[Applaudissements]
une fois de plus c'est encore de la
communication je n'ai entendu encore une
fois aucun engagement concret de votre
part dans vos paroles à quand les actes
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse ça me donne la
première ministre madame la Première
ministre comme l'écrivait Euripide le
temps révèle tout et n'attend pas d'être
interrogé en effet les années passent et
le scandale de la prévision de la
privatisation pardon des concessions
d'autoroute révèlent des entrailles est
toujours plus nausées à bond du système
oligarchique qui pile les Français les
mois passent et plus rien ne justifie
votre refus obstiné de reprendre le
contrôle des prix des péages et des
équipements qui devraient appartenir aux
Français les jours passent et
s'enchaînent les révélations
consternantes sur la compromission du
personnel politique français avec ceux
qui se gavent sur le dos des Français le
magazine Marianne a révélé madame la
Première ministre que le secrétariat
général du gouvernement aurait dissimulé
par un faux l'indigence des documents de
travail qui vous ont permis de négocier
un accord en 2015 avec les
concessionnaires d'autoroute vous étiez
alors madame borne directrice de cabinet
de Ségolène Royal et vous avez établi
avec l'ombre des modèles Macron Alexis
Kohler un accord scandaleux qui a offert
9 milliards d'euros au concessionnaire
privé d'autoroute dans la société
Eiffage or
oh madame borne vous avez dirigé la
branche des concessions d'autoroute pour
Eiffage entre 2007 et 2008 ça vous fait
rire pas moi comment avez-vous pu mené
de telles négociations alors que vous
étiez en confident d'intérêt évident à
la tête de ses concessions madame borne
comment pouviez-vous ignorer les
bénéfices intolérables quefact faisaient
sur les péages pourquoi n'avez-vous rien
fait pour établir la justice ni comme
directrice de cabinet ni comme ministre
ni comme première ministre pire encore
alors que vous étiez ministre des
Transports vous avez attribué la
conception de la 79 un contrat juteux de
500 millions d'euros avec une concession
de 48 ans garantissant un rendement
juteux de 5 à 10% qui a obtenu cette
concession Eiffage qui peut croire
encore à votre appartient aussi ma
question est simple êtes vos services
des Français ou des Fages
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre chargé des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Tanguy dans le sillage de ce
qu'a dit la première ministre au service
de l'intérêt général je voudrais avoir
un mot en particulier pour si vous le
permettez Stéphane testaud agent des
routes qui est décédé hier je suis allé
voir ses collègues hier après-midi
me permettait en tant que ministre les
transports d'avoir une pensée aussi pour
les agents des routes qui rendent
service et aux Français mais je vois que
ça ne vous intéresse pas mais je vais
répondre à votre question mais c'est
Tanguy je vois que je vois que je vois
que vous et votre démagogie vous portez
bien et je vais vous dire Monsieur
Tanguy j'en ai assez j'en ai ras-le-bol
de votre démagogie au service de votre
démarque de votre électoralisme à
supportable et se complotisme de base
étage qui salit nos agents publics vous
venez de parler du secrétariat général
du gouvernement qui est l'autorité de la
première ministre est composé de
fonctionnaires dévoués je ne supporterai
pas que vous jetiez le soupçon sur le
secrétariat général du Gouvernement je
ne supporterai pas que vous jetiez le
soupçon sur l'administration du
ministère des Transports comme vous
l'avez fait sur l'administration du
ministère de l'Économie à chaque fois
que nous avons été sollicités je l'ai
fait encore la semaine dernière nous
avons répondu nous avons répondu à
chacune de vos demandes nous avons
transmis le rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances j'ai transmis
moi-même la semaine dernière j'ai
transmis moi-même la semaine dernière à
la demande de parlementaire et de
journalistes une note de 2013 sur ce
sujet il n'y a pas lieu d'avoir le
moindre complotisme on peut avoir un
débat politique j'ai été des heures dans
cette émission vous étiez là d'ailleurs
monsieur Tanguy pour répondre à chacune
de vos questions sur les concessions
pour répondre à chacune de vos questions
sur les péages mais cessons ces mots
insupportables qui participent aussi à
cette violence politique nous ne pouvons
pas vivre dans ce climat je vous demande
d'arrêter ce complotisme odieux
parle si tu as des mots plus forts que
les silences ou garde le silence il a
ajouté le silence est un aveu
merci
[Applaudissements]
vous lisez des fiches préparées
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu
pour le groupe CDR
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre des comptes publics
depuis de nombreux mois tous les acteurs
du logement professionnel du bâtiment
promoteur HLM association élu locaux
tire la sonnette d'alarme tous le disent
notre pays est désormais plongé dans
l'une des plus graves crises du logement
de son histoire et évoque même une bombe
sociale à retardement cette crise et la
source d'une immense souffrance sociale
elle pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat et
affaiblit notre économie depuis 2017 sur
de nombreux bancs de l'hémicycle on vous
a alerté sur vos mauvais choix mais une
fois de plus vous n'avez pas écouté
cette crise n'est donc pas le résultat
d'une calamité sans cause mais le
produit de vos orientations politiques
du rabotage des aPL à l'augmentation de
la TVA sur la construction en passant
par les soit les HLM et la suppression
des aides aux mères bâtisseurs vous avez
déséquilibré notre système si singulier
basé sur une économie mixte avec un
secteur privé et un secteur socialisé
jamais la part du PIB de la France
consacré au logement n'a été aussi
faible et si le logement coûte 38
milliards d'euros par an au budget de la
nation il en rapporte 88 milliards au
moment à un moment où le secteur privé
souffre de difficultés liées à
l'inflation il y a urgence à agir pour
redonner au secteur social les moyens de
remplir son rôle contracyclique alors
Monsieur le Ministre m'a proposition
sera raisonnable et simple alors que la
hausse bien légitime du taux du livret A
pèse sur les contes des organismes HLM
allez vous pour relancer la production
supprimer la ponction de 1,5 milliards
d'euros par an dite RLS et revenir au
taux de TVA pour les produits de
première nécessité à 5,5% pour les
constructions de logements conventionnés
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre du Logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Stéphane peu oui le logement est un bien
précieux le logement social on est un
encore plus la le logement vous le savez
est au cœur des préoccupations de ce
gouvernement le Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement rendra ses
premières restitutions dès le 5 juin
nous avons travaillé avec plus de 200
acteurs du logement depuis plusieurs
mois pour faire un certain nombre de
propositions et nous avons déjà agi
d'abord dans le logement social et vous
le savez même si vous avez cité des
difficultés depuis un certain nombre de
mois le logement social n'est pas en
crise systémique et en crise financière
plus de 100 000 agréments ont été donnés
en 2018 et en 2019 si abaisse a été
constaté ces derniers ces deux dernières
années c'est souvent parce que un
certain nombre d'élus locaux ont pris
des décisions contraires à l'intérêt de
leurs concitoyens et ont refusé de
signer des permis de construire
vous le savez comme moi j'ai été élu
local suffisamment et je sais ce qu'un
mère peut faire quand il décide de
construire ou quand il décide de ne pas
construire ensuite la première ministre
l'a déjà la première ministre l'a déjà
annoncé pour faire face à la crise
actuelle parce que nous savons que la
crise de la promotion est aussi une
crise du logement social avec la Caisse
des dépôts et la Caisse des Dépôts
habitat nous allons engager un soutien à
l'acquisition de plus de 20000 logements
et ce programme a déjà été annoncé par
le directeur Lombard et nous allons
continuer dans le case du travail que
nous menons avec Bruno Le Maire et les
banques pour l'accès au taux auprès
pardon en travaillant sur les
possibilités de souplesse pour les
banques sur les taux d'intérêt sur la
durée des prêts et tous ces chantiers
sont en cours ensuite le pacte de
confiance qui a aussi été souhaité par
la première ministre sur lequel nous
travaillons avec l'ensemble des
bailleurs sociaux est en cours de
d'élaboration et nous y travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec un objectif de
signature au Congrès HLM de la fin du
mois de septembre je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Belka belhada
pour le comprenez sans somme merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la
ministre vous venez de lancer
l'opération Tous au jeu la billetterie
populaire de l'État pour les jeux de
paris 2024 nous savons tous que
l'accessibilité sociale des jeux
dépendra notamment de l'accessibilité
sujet que nous avons abordé au sein du
groupe de travail sur les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques que je
coprésident avec Maxime minot grâce à
l'achat des 400 000 billets donnant
accès aux épreuves des jop le
gouvernement confirme son engagement de
contribuer à l'engouement populaire
autour de Paris 2024 on associe à
l'événement la jeunesse les bénévoles du
mouvement sportif les personnes en
situation de handicap ou leurs aidants
je rappelle que la moitié des billets
sont à moins de 50 euros et que 10% sont
au-dessus de 200 euros je n’ignore pas
que les débats engagés sur les prix des
billets ni les critiques adressées au
système des packs qui permet à des
tarifs souvent élevés une participation
aux disciplines des plus populaires je
rappelle que nous avons exigé que les
jeux soient financièrement et qu'il est
vrai pour éviter de faire appel pardon
au contribuable l'opération Tous au jeu
prendra un accord aussi dans nos vies
nos villes au moment du passage de la
flamme et pendant les jeux eux-mêmes
dans l'animation de nos quartiers des
fanzones ou à travers les associations
sportives pour nous au-delà de la seule
question des billets il s'agit de
profiter des jeux olympiques et plus
particulièrement des Jeux paralympiques
pour donner une vocation éducative et de
promotion de l'insertion sociale par le
sport le sport est porteur de valeur de
diversité d'inclusion il est essentiel
pour faire évoluer le regard de la
société les jeux représentent plus que
qu'une polémique sur les prix des
billets pouvez-vous madame la ministre
nous en dire plus sur l'opération Tous
au jeu nous préciser les répartis la
répartition et les bénéficiaires des
billets pour les épreuves et la
cérémonie d'ouverture ainsi que
l'implication des collectivités aux
côtés de l'État merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Amélie
ou des accastera ministre des Sports des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
belkir bellada vous l'avez dit on veut
des beaux jeux on veut des grands jeux
on veut en même temps éviter un impôts
Jo il faut donc accepter qu'il y ait des
recettes de billetterie ces recettes de
billetterie avec des prix élevés pour
les plus élevés d'entre eux permettent
aussi de financer l'entrée de gamme avec
ce million de place à 24 euros seulement
comme nous l'a demandé le président de
la République comme nous l'a demandé la
première ministre nous serons au
rendez-vous de l'impératif
d'accessibilité
tarifaire et social de ces jeux c'est
pourquoi nous avons lancé ce programme
de billetterie populaire de l'État doté
de 400 000 billets le 19 mai dernier
tous au jeu c'est quoi 400 000 billets
260 000 qui viendront doter la jeunesse
des élèves de CM1 à la terminale en
métropole et outre-mer des élèves qui
relèvent des élèves défavorisés des
jeunes défavorisés qui relèvent de
l'Aide Sociale à des enfants qui sont
engagés dans des programmes
d'accompagnement pour les vacances
quartiers d'été colos apprenantes des
jeunes qui s'illustrent de manière
exemplaire par leur engagement citoyen
ou associatifs des étudiants boursiers
100 000 bénévoles du mouvement sportif
17500 personnes en situation de handicap
et leurs aidants ainsi que 25 000 agents
de catégories B et C particulièrement
engagés dans la préparation de ces jeux
c'est toutes ces populations là à qui
nous allons pouvoir offrir cette
billetterie gratuite c'est un effort
sans précédent c'est un effort inédit
les collectivités hautes rajoutent à ces
400 000 billets une dotation de 500 000
et le comité d'organisation lui-même
mettra 100 000 billets à disposition des
publics prioritaires au global c'est
donc un million de billets que nous
serons en capacité d'offrir en
complément des places qui seront
gratuites sur les chaos pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture et qui feront de
ces jeux au global 10% 10% des billets
et des épreuves avec cette billetterie
offerte au public pour rendre les
Français fiers et le plus grand nombre
possible heureux derrière ces événements
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christian
Baptiste pour le groupe socialiste
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mais très chers collègues
les travailleuses de Vertbaudet dans le
Nord qui depuis deux mois se battent
pour une augmentation de salaire
conserve une détermination forte face à
la répression patronale judiciaire et
policière
si je fais référence à ce mouvement qui
est d'actualité c'est pour attirer votre
attention sur un événement majeur de
l'histoire de notre pays je parle des
événements des émeutes de mai 1967 en
Guadeloupe
ont été un tournant dans la lutte pour
la reconnaissance des droits et de la
dignité des Guadeloupe et manifestations
et les affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre on secouait l'île révélant la
profonde les profondes inégalités
économiques sociales et raciales qui
persistait en Guadeloupe à l'époque
c'est pourquoi je souhaite aborder la
question de la déclassification totale
des archives comprenez par ici que la
transparence est essentielle pour guérir
les plaies du passé et progresser vers
une société plus juste et équitable
j'exhorte donc le gouvernement à prendre
des mesures concrètes pour la
déclassification totale de ces archives
les guadeloupéen et tous les citoyens de
notre pays méritent de connaître la
vérité d'apprendre notre ici pour
construire un avenir meilleur ma
question est donc la suivante monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et de
l'outre-mer référence faite à la
décision du Président de la République
tendant à la déclassification totale des
archives relatives à la guerre d'Algérie
pouvez-vous nous indiquer les mesures
spécifiques que le gouvernement envisage
de prendre afin de tendre cette
déclassification totale des archives de
même nature à l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer en se compris la Guadeloupe
le cas échéant quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous offrir quant à la
transparence du processus de
décalcification totale des archives et à
l'accès de ces documents pour les
chercheurs et les citoyens intéressés je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Jean-François
caraco ministre des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député Christian
Baptiste vous évoquez en effet un
épisode douloureux de l'histoire de la
Guadeloupe et de la France les émeutes
de mai 1977 en octobre 2016
le gouvernement d'alors a pris ses
responsabilités et le ministre de
l'Outre-mer a mis en place une
commission chargée de faire la lumière
sur ces événements les conclusions sont
rendues et nous les partageons la
secrétaire général de la commission
l'historienne Michel ancarini Fournet la
depuis publié une histoire populaire de
la franchise zone où elle repasse
l'événement dans l'histoire longue à 50
ans de distance
il s'agit d'être transparent et je n'ai
pas demandé pour donner une version
officielle et je ne peux vous en dire
que ce que j'en connais le 26 mai 1967
en effet des ouvriers du bâtiment à
Pointe-à-Pitre se mettent en grève pour
demander une augmentation de salaire de
2,5 % la grève devient une émeute un
militant indépendantiste populaire
Jacques Nestor est tué des armureries
sont pillées les émeutes débouchent sur
huit autres morts à tout le mois
concernant les émeutes de 67 comme sur
les autres drames qui ont marqué
l'histoire des Antilles je dirais encore
et toujours qu'ils ne sont pas assez
étudiés non seulement d'outre-mer mais
aussi dans l'Hexagone je vais citer le
rapport de la commission Stora
l'histoire des Antilles de la Guyane
comme de la Réunion reste encore
méconnue dans l'Hexagone
après la fin des accords d'Évian
celle-ci semble complètement disparaître
de l'histoire nationale nous devrons
travailler à la faire connaître et le
gouvernement et y prêt à prendre toute
sa part la mémoire fut-elle terrible
doit nous aider à construire de l'avenir
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous faisons en
ce jour du 23 mai où nous célébrons la
fin de l'esclavage et où nous remémorons
toutes les victimes quant à votre quant
à votre décision de déclassification je
rêve de ne pas avoir eu votre question à
l'avance si ce n'est à l'instant je ne
peux donc vous répondre tout de suite
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick noder
pour le groupe les républicains
madame madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre ce matin un
terrible drame a frappé le monde médical
de notre pays une infirmière du CHU de
Reims a succombé à ses blessures après
avoir été adressé au couteau cet homme
si blanc nous blouse blanche s'en est
également pris à une secrétaire médicale
la licence dans un état très critique je
tiens comme médecin mais aussi comme
député à adresser mes pensées aux
proches de cette infirmière et mon
soutien à l'ensemble de la communauté
médicale à laquelle j'appartiens la
facilité avec laquelle cet individu a pu
commettre cet acte le suivi le fait de
son suivi psychiatrique était suspendu
qu'il est bénéficié en juin 2022 d'une
ordonnance de non-lieu pour une
responsabilité pénale rester sans suite
et surtout le fait que ce drame ne soit
pas le premier dans notre pays tout cela
doit nous alerter sur une forme de
tolérance de l'État qui s'est installé
au détriment de la sécurité de nos
soignants on déplore une hausse de 23%
des incidences violents contre les
soignants soit 1200 incidents 2022 un
record près de 40% des professionnels de
santé hospitaliers ont suivi des
agressions physiques ils vont au travail
avec la boule au ventre cet événement
tragique pose aussi et malheureusement
la question de la prise en charge
psychiatrique madame la Première
ministre je vous le demande quand
allez-vous fournir une réponse à la
hauteur de l'urgence quand allez-vous
financer un grand plan d'ampleur pour la
psychiatrie et la pseudo-psychiatrie
grand oubliés de nos politiques de santé
à quand les moyens massifs pour les
structures de soins de recherche et
d'enseignement et enfin quand allez-vous
véritablement punir ceux qui s'en
prennent aux agents du service public
j'ai une proposition mettez à l'ordre du
jour la proposition de loi que j'ai
déposé avec mes collègues les
républicains pour rétablir les plaines
planchers pour les individus qui s'en
prennent à ceux qui nous soignent et qui
nous protègent aucun soignant ne devrait
risquer sa vie à protéger celle des
autres je vous remercie merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
dans la présidence mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député notaire
je m'associe bien sûr à votre soutien
pour l'ensemble on se demande la
communauté médicale mais aussi
l'ensemble des soignants qui soient
d'ailleurs à l'hôpital qui soit
également dans l'exercice libéral comme
je l'ai dit le nombre d'agressions ne
cesse d'augmenter souvent qualifié de
petites agressions ou simplement
d'incivilité ce qui est totalement
insupportable et une action forte a déjà
être de faire reconnaître aux soignants
ses incivilités c'est agressions de les
dénoncer de ne plus les accepter trop
souvent on accepte dans son exercice
professionnel de se faire injurier pour
une raison pour une autre ça doit rester
totalement inacceptable concernant
l'individu qui est le responsable de
cette de cette agression je voudrais il
a été interpellé très rapidement il
avait
des propos
curieux semblent-ils c'est une personne
qui a des lourds antécédents
psychiatriques pour autant l'enquête
diligentée par le procureur de la
République est en cours et comme je le
disais tout à l'heure nous sommes autant
du recueillement laissons l'enquête se
conduire pour savoir exactement quels
sont non seulement les circonstances
mais les circonstances globales et les
la volonté de cet acte par cette
personne concernant la psychiatrie notre
psychiatrie comme les urgences comme les
maternités comme notre système de santé
cela fait des mois des années qu'il est
en difficulté nous le savons la
psychiatrie des Assises de la
psychiatrie de l'année dernière nous ont
permis de mettre en place un certain
nombre de solutions je pense aux maisons
des adolescents je pense aussi au mon
parcours psy qui a permis de faire plus
de 300 000 consultations pour les gens
les plus difficiles nous aurons à
continuer cela bien entendu dans un une
poursuite de ce plan pour la psychiatrie
en recrutant des professionnels mais
aussi en travaillant sur le partage de
compétences parce que je le redis c'est
pas en claquant des doigts que nous
aurons plus de médecins demain il faudra
attendre 10 ans de ce partage de
compétences avec des infirmières
spécialisés en psychiatrie est une des
solutions que nous déployons merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
nodert merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse médicale mais la question
est surtout pénale et j'aurais souhaité
que le garde des sceaux puisse
s'exprimer sur le dogmatisme vis-à-vis
des peines plancher merci
la parole est à Monsieur François
Piquemal pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald de
Darmanin pendant les vacances de
Printemps des centaines de directrices
et directeurs d'école à Toulouse et dans
l'Hérault ont reçu un mail émanant de
vos services les enjoignants à
transmettre le taux d'absentéisme le 21
avril soit le jour de l'Aïd votre
demande a choqué de nombreux de nos
concitoyens y compris j'en suis certain
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
lui-même et pour cause elle contrevient
au principe de laïcité alors que les
autorisations d'absence pour fêtent
religieuses sont régies par le code de
l'éducation elle dresse un lien entre la
sécurité intérieure et nos compatriotes
de confession musulmane qui ne
contribuent qui contribue à les
stigmatiser encore davantage pour
mémoire le fichage religieux et ethnique
est interdit par la loi et cet événement
nous rappelle des heures sombres de
notre histoire monsieur Darmanin
pouvez-vous donc nous dire quel est
l'objectif de cette demande
appliquer à tout le territoire national
allez-vous demander le taux
d'absentéisme pour toutes les fêtes
religieuses et faire de la participation
à ces événements des signes de
radicalisation avez-vous un problème
vous-même peut-être avec la laïcité
pourquoi cette Islam ophobie partageait
avec Madame Le Pen êtes-vous enfin prêt
à formuler des excuses auprès du
personnel enseignant et de nos
concitoyens qui se sont sentis blessés
par cette nouvelle affaire
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sonia baquet secrétaire d'État chargé de
la citoyenneté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
pickman non monsieur le député il n'y a
pas de fichage des élèves en fonction de
leur appartenance religieuse dans
l'école de la République mais oui il y a
un suivi sur tout le territoire national
du déroulement général des fêtes
religieuses dans la sphère publique et
il y a un suivi pour toutes les fesses
pour toutes les fêtes religieuses il y a
un suivi des heures et de la
fréquentation des grandes messes pour la
religion catholique il y a un suivi du
déroulement des processions et des
célébrations pour la pour la communauté
juive juive pardon dans le cadre de la
Fête des Lumières
[Musique]
et ne pas suivre ne pas suivre l'impact
de ces fêtes religieuses seraient une
faute des services de renseignement
d'ailleurs ce suivi a été fait également
lors des précédents quinquennat quel que
soit la majorité et c'est bien normal
donc oui la demande a peut-être été
formulée de manière maladroite mais non
demandez des informations générales sur
l'impact des faits religieuses ne
signifie pas de quelconque attention
agressive à l'égard d'une quelconque
religion et vous demandez des excuses
monsieur le député c'est vous qui
devriez présenter des excuses parce que
c'est vous qui affaiblissez la
République en étant d'une telle mauvaise
foi je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre mal
oui je vois que vos réponses restent
ambiguë un peu comme le rapport la
laïcité de Monsieur Darmanin qui se
défaussent je regrette je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas un mot d'excuse pour
ceux qui ont été blessés par cet
événement et ne vous en déplaise à vous
et à l'extrême droite au même titre que
Yom Kippour que la fête de la Nativité
que le V5 que la théophanie l'Aïd est
une fête française car la République
elle se bien commun qui rend harmonieuse
nos différences face à votre mollet si
vos dérives nous la défendrons
merci beaucoup monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Maud Gatel pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous avez présenté
hier les premiers axes du plan de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre afin
de nous conformer à la feuille
européenne qui prévoit une baisse de 50
% des émissions d'ici à 2030 et la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 le
respect de ce cadre européen dans le
droit fil des accords de Paris est un
pré requis pour faire face à l'urgence
écologique suivant les préconisations du
GIEC la France est engagée sur une
réduction à 270 millions de tonnes
équivalents CO2 d'ici 2030 soit un
doublement de la baisse de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre le chemin qu'il
reste à parcourir nécessite une
accélération collective et la
mobilisation de tous
parallèlement à l'atténuation les
efforts doivent également porter sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique
car s'adapter ce n'est en rien renoncé
s'adapter c'est anticiper les
conséquences du changement climatique
dont on sait qu'il touche davantage les
plus vulnérables
Paris à 50 degrés ne relève
malheureusement pas de la
science-fiction et les conséquences
seront majeures sur ces habitants je
pense notamment à la question du
logement la rénovation thermique doit
désormais être pensée pour se protéger
des pics de chaleur qui rendront
certains appartements inhabitables alors
que le marché connaît une importante
tension les politiques d'adaptation
doivent veiller à ce que l'habitabilité
soit renforcée
face au phénomène météorologiques
extrême l'insécurité alimentaire
l'impact sur la biodiversité les
conséquences sur la santé l'adaptation
n'est pas une option et elle doit être
socialement juste pour que chacun y
adhère monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires vous avez annoncé le
lancement d'une large concertation pour
préparer le troisième plan national
d'adaptation changement climatique
pouvez-vous nous indiquer les actes de
travail que vous proposez pour prévenir
l'escalade des risques et nous préciser
comment le plan s'articulera avec le
fond vert je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la députée la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Bachut ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
gatelle depuis ce matin depuis la fin de
la matinée précisément la trajectoire
d'adaptation au changement climatique
est effectivement en ligne un document
d'une trentaine de pages réalisé par
l'ensemble des agences qui dépendent du
pôle ministériel
l'ADM Météo France l'ofb et qui tourne
le dos à des années pendant lesquelles
on n'a pas parlé d'adaptation
la preuve c'est que même aujourd'hui
certains qui se prétend d'écologistes et
qui essayent de couvrir ma voix en
braillant même si tout le monde ne
l'entend pas n'ont rien dit sur ces
sujets et aujourd'hui ils font semblant
de dire qu'une trajectoire d'adaptation
à 4 degrés ce serait la preuve que nous
aurions renoncé à nos ambitions je les
invite à se référer au rapport du GIEC à
regarder ce que disent les climatologues
et entendre y compris ces derniers jours
ce que les spécialistes disaient
on peut tromper tout le monde un certain
temps on peut tromper certains tout le
temps on peut pas tromper tout le monde
tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît on laisse le ministre
répondre s'il vous plaît on laisse le
ministre épaule vous n'avez pas la
parole allez-y monsieur le ministre
certains illustrent le respect qu'il
porte y compris au travail des agents du
ministère de l'Environnement aux agences
qui ont travaillé aux experts qui se
sont exprimés en écoutant même pas les
réponses et en twitant plus vite que ce
que les experts sont capables de lire et
de dire alors je vais faire en sorte de
vous répondre quel que soit la vitesse à
laquelle nous allons baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
notre pays qui a doublé ce rythme de
baisse au cours de ces dernières années
qui est rendu à 25% de baise par rapport
à 1990 malheureusement quand on le
compare quand on le met sur le plan
global les experts du GIEC nous disent à
la minute où nous parlons nous ne sommes
pas sur une trajectoire mondiale de
respect des accords de Paris et à ce
cette vitesse-là c'est pas un et demi
c'est entre 2,8 et 3 2 d'augmentation
des températures c'est à dire 4 pour la
France puisqu'une partie de la
température est absorbée par les océans
4 de grés ça veut dire repenser nos la
résilience de nos infrastructures de
transport de télécommunications ça veut
dire mieux préserver la biodiversité
c'est le sens de la concertation qui a
été lancée ce matin je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Michel casser
l'année pour le groupe liote
[Applaudissements]
au moment où devrait reprendre les
discussions entre le gouvernement et les
élus je voudrais évoquer une fois de
plus la question Corse notre île souffre
depuis des lustres d'une accumulation de
problèmes sociaux économiques culturelle
sans que des solutions adaptées et
jamais été diligentes il est nécessaire
de répondre à une situation qui fait
coexister précarité des possessions à
culturation et spéculations débridée une
majorité de Corse et d'élus se
rejoignent sur la nécessité de règlement
globale qui passe par un statut
spécifique de la Corse et des et
des compétences permettant d'améliorer
les choses nous souhaitons pour notre
part une société fraternelle est ouverte
mais tout autant inscrite dans une
continuité historique qui préserve notre
culture notre sentiment d'appartenance
commun et notre personnalité au-delà de
cet aspect institutionnel reste posé des
problèmes majeurs j'ai ainsi demandé à
plusieurs reprises que nous soit
communiqué les comptes financiers de
l'île
il est impossible de dessiner les
contours des statut fiscal que nous
souhaitons sans savoir ce que l'écorce
payent d'impôts ou ce que l'État verse
en Corse je n'obtiens aucune réponse de
même je ne réussis pas obtenir la
publication du rapport de la commission
nationale d'investissement santé selon
nécessité doit construction d'un nouvel
hôpital à Bastia pas plus que nous
n'obtenons la contractualisation des
trois écoles immersives en langue corse
malgré l'extrême modestie de son cou
madame la Première ministre ces silences
répétées sont inquiétants la lourdeur
des tâches qui pèse sur le gouvernement
ne doit pas conduire à sous-estimer et
écarter les besoins que l'accord
s'exprime depuis des siècles nous
sortirions grandi tous si nous avons
Sion enfin dans la prise en compte d'une
situation pénible que nous souhaitons
ardemment voir régler de façon positive
si mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Michel Castellani c'est une belle chose
que de pouvoir parler de la Corse dans
cette hémistique à la veille vous le
savez bien de la nouvelle réunion que
nous tiendrons avec l'ensemble des élus
de Corse avec vous-même avec le
président siméone qui parlera jeudi avec
les ministres Béchu et Cloud de logement
d'urbanisme question très importante que
vous avez déjà évoquée pardon monsieur
le député mais je veux redire d'abord
toutes les avancées qu'il y a eu encore
sur soulevénement d'Emmanuel Macron la
continuité territoriale et notamment le
travail que nous avons fait pour
convaincre la Commission européenne en
permacer Clément bonne de son
application et je crois que le président
Simoni s'en ai fait citer publiquement
vous avez pu constater que dans la
transition énergétique et notamment dans
la programmation de l'énergie la
première ministre a rendu des arbitrages
très favorables à la rénovation des
logements à Ajaccio et à Bastia
président siméonie s'en est ému
également et vous savez bien que pendant
le covid nous avons soutenu encore plus
que d'autres territoires le territoire
corse l'île de beauté bien évidemment
parce que l'avait une aide particulière
à portée notamment sur la question du
tourisme il y a d'autres questions vous
avez raison les questions médicales
l'accord s'offre de démographie médicale
plus encore que d'autres territoires
vous parlez de l'hôpital de Bastia ou de
la maternité de Porto-Vecchio avec le
ministre de la Santé nous y travaillons
mon cabinet vous le savez s'est rendu
sur place et nous y travaillerons très
bientôt j'ai rassuré moi-même le maire
de Bastia dans votre circonscription
c'est aussi le cas des données la DGFiP
que Gabriel Attal nous a évidemment
travaillé avec les services et seront
rendus pour la mi-juin pour que fin juin
lorsque nous aurons le comité
stratégique sur la fiscalité toutes les
données soient fournies à l'ensemble des
élus de Corse pour travailler au statut
fiscal nous verrons évidemment nous
sommes d'accord sur ce statut bien
évidemment croyez bien monsieur le
député que la Corse est au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement et
singulièrement au cœur de mes propres
préoccupations
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Castellani
ministre un de la difficulté de votre
tâche d'autres se sont cassés les dents
sur la Corse je voudrais vous dire une
rien par la contrainte ou par la
répression nous le comptons sur vous
vraiment pour assurer des réponses à la
hauteur des enjeux c'est c'est très
attendu encore ça c'est pas seulement
qu'en Corse d'ailleurs merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Thibault Bazin pour le complet
républicain
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre aidez les Françaises
et les Français qui travaillent dur et
qui veulent bien élever leurs enfants
voilà l'objectif affiché par le
Président de la République dans son
interview du 15 mai dernier voilà une
noble ambition mais qu'avez-vous fait
jusqu'à lors pour aider les familles de
classement moyenne tout l'inverse vous
avez confirmé les mesures néfastes pris
sous le quinquennat de François Hollande
vous avez ainsi remis en cause
l'universalité de la politique familiale
en mettant sous condition de ressources
et les allocations familiales vous avez
confirmé la diminution du quotient
familial de 834 euros et depuis 2017
vous avez pénalisé encore davantage les
familles vous avez raboté en 2018 la
prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant
imaginez des couples de parents qui
travaillent tous les deux avec un revenu
équivalent au SMIC ont pu perdre jusqu'à
546 euros sur la durée totale vous avez
supprimé en 2020 la majoration de
l'indemnité journalière en cas de
maladie pour les parents de trois
enfants ou plus soit une perte de 33%
depuis 2018 vous vous devez divisé par
deux sur 95% de notre territoire la
quantité finançable du prêt à taux zéro
pour toutes les familles de classe
moyenne qui aspirent à devenir
propriétaire et offrir ainsi un foyer
adapté pour accueillir leurs enfants le
nombre de PTZ ainsi été divisé par deux
en cinq ans et ce n'est donc pas sa
prolongation en l'état pour 2024 qui
sera suffisante pour enrayer cette chute
avec des taux d'intérêt qui s'envole
3,15% en moyenne sans compter les
assurances vos décisions ont pénalisé le
pouvoir d'achat de nos familles résultat
en 2022 seulement 723000 bébés sont nés
en France c'est le plus faible nombre de
naissances depuis la prière il y a donc
urgence à agir pour vraiment aider les
Français qui travaillent dur et qui
veulent bien élever leurs enfants alors
ma question sera direct quelle mesure
concrète comptez-vous prendre pour mieux
soutenir ces familles de classe moyenne
je vous remercie monsieur le minis
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Geneviève dariussec ministre
délégué chargé des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Thibault Bazin vous vous posez
une question importante
c'est la question de la de la natalité
est plutôt de la dénatalité qui sévit
dans notre pays comme dans toute l'Union
enfin l'Union européenne est plus
largement les pays occidentaux dans une
transition qui est maintenant
relativement longue en France la
population est passée de 42 millions
1950 à 68 millions aujourd'hui mais la
natalité stagne depuis 1970 et recule
depuis 2015 et de l'autre côté la
population vieillit puisque l'espérance
de vie s'allonge ce dont il faut bien
sûr se féliciter alors il faut entendre
l'inquiétude exprimée par certains de
nos concitoyens et par vous-même
d'ailleurs qui redoute pour certains le
déclin dans notre pays incarné par un
déclassement démographique et le trop de
natalité doit être au carrefour de est
au carrefour de tous les enjeux
productifs sociaux culturels et
environnementaux alors d'abord je
voudrais que on reconnaisse que dans
notre pays et bien le taux de fécondité
est encore à 1,9 enfants 2022 soit le
plus élevé d'Europe et nous étudions
ensemble le recul de notre natalité bien
sûr le nombre de femmes à l'âge de
procurer est moins important le recul de
l'âge de la maternité ainsi que les
impacts économiques et environnementaux
alors oui les politiques familiales sont
pour le gouvernement une politique
importante et c'est le sens des
chantiers structurants qui ont été
menées par Jean-Christophe combe je
pense à la réforme du complément du mode
de garde voté en loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale en 2023 et à la mise en
place du service public de la petite
enfance sur lequel nous pouvons nous
entendre afin
d'avoir
[Musique]
merci madame la ministre monsieur Bazin
madame la ministre ce n'est pas
suffisant pour enrayer le déclin si on
veut assurer le renouvellement des
générations il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin et rétablir une politique
ambitieuse en termes de politique
familiale avec un taux de renouvellement
d'un virgule 8 c'est bien insuffisant
pour assurer ce renouvellement
génération merci la parole est à Madame
Emmanuelle Ménard
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre comme
beaucoup de communes françaises Béziers
et jumelée avec plusieurs villes une
cité allemande et LeBron mais aussi la
petite ville martyr de Malula en
syrief en Ukraine pour témoigner de
notre solidarité face à l'invasion russe
et depuis hier soir Thaïlande dans le
sud de l'île de Taïwan il s'agit pour
notre conseil municipal de se ranger aux
côtés d'une démocratie menacée d'être
envahie par la dictature communiste qui
règne à Pékin il s'agit de rappeler que
ce pays incarne les valeurs dont nous
nous réclamons à longueur de discours
ici même à la tribune de notre assemblée
ce jumelage a été voté à la quasi
unanimité de notre conseil municipal une
seule voie a manqué celle de l'élu
communiste mais ça détonnera personne
c'est dans ce cadre que je vous demande
madame la ministre de peser de tout
votre poids pour que Taiwan soit invité
à participer comme observateur à 76e
Assemblée mondiale de la santé faut-il
rappeler que c'est à Taïwan que c'est
Taïwan qui la première a alerter l'OMS
de cas suspect d'une pneumonie atypique
en Chine nous étions en décembre 2019 et
on ne parlait pas encore de la covid
dans la foulée Taïwan a offert des
masques chirurgicaux à plus de 80 pays
dans le monde or aujourd'hui sous la
pression des autocrates chinois l'OMS
refuse la participation de Taïwan à cet
assemblée au détriment de la santé de
tous comme quoi la politique la pire des
politiques prend une fois encore le pas
sur l'intérêt des habitants de notre
monde ma question est donc simple que
compte faire la France madame la
ministre pour que Taïwan soit admise au
titre d'observateur auprès de l'OMS
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Ménard la politique de la
France s'agissant de Taïwan et constante
nous n'avons pas de relation
diplomatique avec la One parce que nous
ne reconnaissons pas Taïwan comme un
état mais nous avons des relations d'une
autre nature et dans ce cadre la France
est attachée comme votre ville à
développer ses coopération avec Taïwan
elle le fait notamment dans le domaine
économique mais le fait aussi dans le
domaine scientifique universitaire ou
culturel et donc oui nous pensons qu'il
est utile que Taïwan puisse participer
aux travaux d'organisation
internationale dès lors que cette
participation n'emporte pas le statut
d’état et nous souhaitons ainsi que
Taïwan puisse à nouveau parce que
c'était le cas dans le passé participé
travaux de l'Organisation Mondiale de la
Santé et nous faisons même avec
constance des démarches en ce sens avec
de nombreux partenaires je les dis
souvent et le ministre de la Santé l'a
dit à l'OMS hier notre politique est
aussi constante s'agissant du détroit de
Taïwan nous sommes opposés à toute
modification unilatérale du statu quo
s'agissant daiwan et nous sommes
attachés pareillement à faire respecter
la liberté de navigation dans les eaux
internationales et cette position n'est
pas que déclaratoire elle se traduit en
acte très concrètement notre marine
nationale fait passer des navires dans
le détroit témoins elle l'a fait encore
il y a quelques semaines vous le voyez
madame la députée cohérence et Constance
telle est la politique de la France
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
allez-y ma chère collègues merci Madame
la Ministre cohérence et constante
constance peut-être aurait-il fallu
aussi un peu plus de fermeté comme
d'autres pays comme le Japon le Canada
l'Australie ou d'autres encore la
Tchéquie la Lituanie pour ne citer que
mais il y en a d'autres qui
insiste avec beaucoup de fermeté pour
que Taïwan fasse
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Michael taverne
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi avant tout
d'exprimer aussi mon émotion à la suite
du décès de Manon Steven et Paul
policier au commissariat de Roubaix
depuis toujours les policiers du
rassemblement national soutiennent les
forces de l'ordre s'il y a bien un
groupe ou siège des députés qui ont été
policiers gendarmes sapeurs-pompiers et
qui ont assuré la sécurité des Français
pendant des années souvent au péril de
leur vie c'est celui du rassemblement
national
malgré vos annonces et votre
communication votre politique de
sécurité est un échec vous êtes présents
partout mais efficace nulle part par
contre monsieur le ministre vous gardez
bien de dire que les démissions
s'enchaînent dans la police et la
gendarmerie depuis 2020 c'est du jamais
vu et sera cela vous rend mal à l'aise
car c'est la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement et ce sont les Français qui
en paix le prix selon la Cour des
comptes la police nationale a connu 10
1840 départs en 2021 la gendarmerie
15000 et la situation a empiré en 2022
les forces de l'ordre doutes de vous
n'ont plus confiance en votre politique
éparte malgré l'amour pour leur
profession au service du pays les motifs
sont tellement prévisibles la
présomption de culpabilité et des
conditions au travail déplorable le
laxisme judiciaire le rouleau
compresseur médiatique à chaque
intervention sensible une gestion
humaine catastrophique et deux ans de
plus à se prendre des boules de pétanque
du mortier avec votre bénédiction pour
un salaire d'appel 2000 € par mois mes
chers collègues vous vous levez pour
soutenir les forces de l'ordre et dans
le même temps vous refusez de voter une
loi de notre collègue Naïma muchu
pourtant de votre majorité pour mieux
lutter contre la récidive et ainsi
alourdir les peines pour les auteurs
d'agression envers les forces de l'ordre
et les élus donc la prochaine fois
réfléchissez aux conséquences que cela
engendre ma question est donc simple
monsieur le ministre qu'allez-vous faire
pour la fidélisation et ainsi me motiver
les troupes
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin et des
Outre-mer
merci Madame Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs débutez monsieur le député je
veux évidemment m'associer à l'hommage
que vous avez rendu comme la rendue même
la présidente et même après ministre aux
trois policiers du Nord qui
effectivement touche beaucoup leurs
collègues non seulement du Nord mais
vous le savez de la police nationale
d'ailleurs à ce commissariat de Roubaix
vous étiez présent monsieur le député je
crois que le député Chenu était présent
comme d'autres ici il y a eu un
témoignage très très touchant du major
qui a voulu prendre la parole à la fin
et je remercie des mots c'est dommage
que vous les avez pas prononcés ici
parce que malgré la peine de ses
collègues il la remercier je vous vois
rocher de la tête c'est dommage les
efforts que nous avons fait
collectivement et notamment sur ce
gouvernement pour leur donner du
matériel des effectifs et du soutien et
qui n'a dit que pour rien au monde lui
et ses collègues ne changerait le métier
c'est dommage pas à l'avoir appelé ici
Monsieur le Député alors que vous étiez
dans ce commissariat
c'est dommage monsieur le député parce
que par ailleurs indépendamment de
l'émotion qui ne vous a manifestement
pas étreint devant ce témoignage vous
avez mal vous avez mal vous avez mal
interprété les les chiffres de la Cour
des comptes mais c'est vrai que comme
disait le Churchill je ne crois aux
statistiques que lorsque les moi-même
falsifié s'il y a un quart des policiers
qui démissionnent c'est des policiers
adjoints pour devenir gardien de la paix
parce que nous avons ouvert 8000 postes
dans la police nationale si il y a
Monsieur le Député 34% des gendarmes qui
démissionnent c'est pour devenir
sous-officier parce que nous en
multiplié par deux le nombre de
sous-officiers gendarmerie nationale
bien dans la police nationale un tiers
d'augmentation de départ c'est parce que
les gens partent à la retraite parce que
nous leur permettons d'être au PJ et de
revenir dans la réserve opérationnelle
donc monsieur député c'est tout
l'inverse manifestement fort tourner sur
le terrain
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur taverne monsieur le ministre
votre réponse est aussi mauvaise que
votre bilan j'étais acteur et policier
terrain notamment à Roubaix donc ces
collèges les connaissais très bien
relisez le rapport de la Cour des
comptes c'est un phénomène de fond
mettez-vous
manifestement le député il vaut mieux
entendre un major du commissariat de
Roubaix qui a député du rassemblement
national qui a envie de faire de la
démagogie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Sandra Marsault
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
le ministre 60 jours de canicule par an
la quasi-totalité des forêts du pourtour
méditerranéen touchés par les incendies
la disparition complète des glaciers de
notre pays un nombre plus important de
maisons fissurée jusqu'à 50 000
logements touchés par l'érosion côtière
c'est un scénario digne d'un film
catastrophe où les températures
augmenteraient de plus 4 degrés en 2100
c'est pourtant cette hypothèse certes
pessimiste que notre pays doit retenir
pour anticiper les réponses à apporter
en responsabilité à travers le plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique
annoncé par le président de la
République depuis quelques années nos
concitoyens prennent conscience du
réchauffement climatique mondial qui a
déjà des impacts très concrets jusque
dans notre vie quotidienne l'accord de
Paris a posé les bases des mesures
globales appliquées sur l'ensemble de la
planète pour limiter le enfants
climatique a plus 1,5 degrés mais les
objectifs de différents pays sont déjà
loin d'être tenus nous devons
collectivement changer nos habitudes
adopter les bons gestes appliquer de
nouvelles normes techniques dans tous
les domaines transport habitat industrie
énergie les risques naturels vont
s'intensifier et la charge pour notre
pays pourraient dépasser sur ces risques
naturels les 2 milliards d'euros par an
la feuille de route du gouvernement est
claire pour accompagner cette transition
écologique aussi alors qu'aujourd'hui
s'ouvrent cette phase et vous en avez
déjà parlé de consultation publique
pouvez-vous nous présenter les objectifs
de cette démarche vos axes
d'interventions les moyens aussi pour
entre autres phénomènes lutter contre la
sécheresse qui s'installe dans notre
pays je vous remercie je vous remercie
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Marceau et j'en profite pour finir de
répondre à Madame la Députée Gatel
à l'instar d'un certain nombre d’autres
pays autour de nous je pense à
l’autriche je pense à l'Allemagne je
pense au Québec je pense au Japon
assumer une trajectoire de réchauffement
à laquelle nous devons nous adapter qui
n'est pas lié à l'accord de Paris mais
qui correspond à ce que disent les
experts c'est une responsabilité
politique de premier plan d'un côté on
se bat pour ne pas dépasser le 1/2 de
l'autre on regarde en face l'ONU et le
GIEC qui disent le monde ne va pas dans
la bonne trajectoire et au bon rythme et
nous sommes partis pour une augmentation
des températures qui correspond à un
câble degrés chez nous
l'objectif de la consultation on sait ce
matin c'est de bien faire comprendre à
nos concitoyens que 4 degrés ça n'est
pas ce passé d'un pull un soir de
printemps pouvoir rester en T-shirt plus
longtemps l'été
c'est pas le sujet du réchauffement
c'est le sujet du dérèglement climatique
c'est des sécheresse multipliées par 5
c'est un niveau de la montée des eaux et
une érosion du trait de côte qui sera
deux fois plus importante c'est une
perte d'enneigement qui conduira à ce
que les deux tiers des stations des
Alpes n'est plus de neige pendant une
large partie de l'hiver et c'est une
multiplication des jours de chaleur
intenses pour faire ça pour faire face à
ça il y a l'accélération des politiques
de baisse de nos émissions conduites sur
l'autorité de la première ministre qui
vont être déclinés dans les semaines qui
viennent et il y a en parallèle dans
cette consultation les trois axes
modifier nos référentiels techniques
pour faire en sorte que la totalité de
nos infrastructures de nos réseaux de
transport tiennent compte de ce que vont
être ces pics de chaleur lancer un plan
de gestion des vagues de chaleur qui
sera présentée dans les tous prochains
jours faire en sorte de modifier nos
documents d'urbanisme sur l'érosion du
trait de côte repenser nos dispositifs
d'assurance et notre régime de
catastrophes naturelles réviser en
termes de retrait gonflement d'argile ce
qui va être la réalité de tout ça il y a
en parallèle sans attendre les mesures
du plan qui sont d'ores et déjà des
mesures d'adaptation je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame instinct du groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur bech
je suis présente la France a + 4 degrés
5 fois plus de vagues de chaleur plus 5
degrés en été plus de pluie extrême
objectif affiché sortir la France du
déni climatique et c'est pas la France
qui est dans le déni c'est vous et ça
fait 6 ans que ça dure nous nous avons
entendu le GIEC quand il disait qu'il
nous restait 3 ans pour agir Météo
France et le CNRS qui seul armée parce
que le dérèglement va plus vite que
prévu nous avons vu les incendies la
sécheresse sans précédent et vous
qu'avez-vous fait rien si pardon vous
avez des mantelies notre transport
ferroviaire rouvert une centrale à
charbon et fait construire un port
métallier
et qu'avez-vous fait quand l'Assemblée a
voté 12 milliards supplémentaires pour
la rénovation thermique et 3 milliards
pour le train vous avez tout balayé d'un
revers de 49,3 j'entends encore Gabriel
Attal pleurer ici des larmes de
crocodile sur la terrible dette que nous
il responsable vous lions laissez à la
jeunesse la véritable dette elle est
écologique elle s'alourdit tous les
jours et elle n'est pas transférable pas
annulable même l'économiste Jean
pisaniferi artisan du programme
d'Emmanuel Macron 2017 dit que le
champion de la Terre a perdu un temps
fou qu'il faut investir au moins 66
milliards par an dans la transition
écologique et imposer les riches or
depuis 6 ans vous vous êtes acharné à
toujours baisser la fiscalité toujours
au bénéfice des plus riches et des
actionnaires avec son inaction et son
obsession de la dette le macronisme nous
envoie dans le mur climatique à toute
vitesse c'est quoi votre projet le
suicide collectif pour que vos amis les
riches puissent conserver leur mode de
vie destructeur c'est ça
aujourd'hui madame borne elle féminine
de vouloir subitement respecter les
accords de Paris et nous propose un plan
qui n'en est pas un pas de stratégie
claire pas de mesure contraignante pas
de budget nous n'avons pas le temps de
vos contradictions pas le temps de votre
irresponsabilité criminelle
ou sur les plus riches
abonnez-vous emprunter massivement pour
engager la bifurcation écologique nous
sommes sans doute devant le plus grand
défi qui est connu l'humanité c'est de
notre survie que nous parlons vous
n'avez rien fait et tous emballe
allez-vous enfin instaurer le quoi qu'il
en coûte écologique
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
120 oui c'est le plus grand défi de
notre génération et il mérite qu'on
sorte des postures
votre fascination pour la démocratie
compte tenu de la manière dont vous la
pratiquez à la France insoumise explique
sans doute que vous considériez qu'un
plan ça se décrète sans concertation
assumer que votre bifurcation écologique
c'est du greenwashing de la lutte des
classes ce qui vous importe c'est les
symboles quand on discute de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
vous battez sur des symboles et derrière
la manière dont vous présentez les
choses regardons la réalité en face
ce que la première ministre a commencé à
annoncer c'est quoi 100 milliards
d'euros pour doubler les investissements
ferroviaires le rapport Pisani Ferry a
été commandé par cette majorité la
refonte de ma prime rénove la vote de la
possibilité de pouvoir recourir routière
financement en matière de rénovation
publique c'est cette majorité le plan
forêt le plan haut pendant tout ça non
seulement vous n'écoutez pas vous ne
respectez ni les Français par la
démagogie que vous véhiculez ni le débat
par le fait que vous vous réfugiez dans
des prêts à penser l'inaction climatique
c'est vous depuis que ce gouvernement
est en responsabilité le rythme a baissé
deux fois plus vite les émissions
étaient la baisse des émissions a été
tenue en 2019 en 2020 en 2021 en 2022
arrêtez de mentir aux Français assumer
de les traiter en adultes et en
responsable sortez des positions je vous
assure vous y gagnerez en crédibilité et
le débat en sérénité
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Mathilde
Jonquères pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires et traite
du sujet du biométhane alors que le
gouvernement annonce progressivement
préparer notre pays à un scénario de
réchauffement climatique de 4 degrés
supplémentaires à contrario des 2 degrés
prévu par l'accord de Paris nous
constatons que nos efforts en la matière
montrent déjà des résultats et nous
encourage à poursuivre pour cela le
verdissement du gaz est un des piliers
essentiels de notre lutte en 2021 la
France comptait 16% de gaz naturel dans
son mix énergétique au-delà des efforts
massifs engagés pour l'électrification
les gaz renouvelables et bas carbone
sont nécessaires au remplacement
d'énergie fossiles mais sont aussi la
seule alternative pour la décarbonation
de certains secteurs que ce soit
l'industrie le transport lourd et de
longues distances ou encore
l'agriculture le biométhane est une des
énergies est une énergie des territoires
produites par les territoires sources de
création d'emplois directs et indirects
importants néanmoins un certain nombre
d'acteurs ont besoin d'être rassurés un
pantalon ambition nationale sur le sujet
et soulève et certains soulèvent des
freins à l'investissement parmi lesquels
la diminution de l'engagement de l'État
via les tarifs d'achat et le manque de
visibilité réglementaire ainsi que les
délais de réponse et le manque de
cohérence des services déconcentrés de
l'État portant sur des sujets techniques
tels que le mélange des bouts et des
biochers l'installation de stockage
déportée de digestats en zone agricole
monsieur le ministre mes questions sont
les suivantes la prochaine loi de
programmation de l'énergie et du climat
permettra-t-elle de fixer dès 2023 des
objectifs à la hauteur des enjeux en
relevant par exemple la cible de 10 à
20% des gaz renouvelables à horizon 2030
quelles mesures le Gouvernement
prévoit-il de prendre pour valoriser ce
secteur tout en assurant l'acceptabilité
des projets au niveau local et la
promotion d'un modèle territorial
notamment agricole et enfin le
gouvernement prévoit-il une prise d'un
compte de la cogénération biogaz dans la
revalorisation mise en place depuis
septembre pour lutter contre l'inflation
je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
des Jonquères
je vous demande de pardonner Agnès
panure inache qui aurait aimé vous
répondre mais qui est à Bordeaux pour
les assises de la transition énergétique
votre question sur le biométhane et le
pose plus largement la question du mix
énergétique de notre pays dans ce
domaine on a une ambition
sortir de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et pour ce faire on a deux
voies pour y parvenir l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables et le
réinvestissement dans le nucléaire
les mêmes qui critiquent parfois avec
beaucoup de démagogies la réouverture de
centrales à charbon oublie que des pays
qui ont décidé de sortir du nucléaire
c'est pas une centrale qu'ils ont
réouvert de manière temporaire ce sont
des quantités qu'ils ont ouvertes avec
des conséquences pour la santé humaine
qu'on n'a pas fini de mesurer le
biométhane c'est une énergie
renouvelable vous l'avez dit produite
localement qui permet de générer des
emplois à la minute où on se parle grâce
au programme que le gouvernement a
conduit grâce à l'accélération du
soutien au cours de ces dernières années
c'est 10 Terra waters de biométhane que
notre pays produit et dans quelques mois
à l'été dans le cadre de la révision de
la PPE nous aurons précisément à
répondre à la question que vous posez et
ce qu'il faut rester un mix énergétique
attendu qui est de l'ordre de 10% ou
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin et se
fixer comme ambition un doublement de
cette capacité de production biométhane
c'est plutôt la piste sur laquelle nous
sommes mais on ajoutant un élément
le bioéthanie peut être utile pour plein
de choses pour remplacer le gaz en
particulier le gaz naturel dans des
chauderies dans des chaufferies biomass
mais il est aussi précieux ce biométhane
pour les secteurs où nous avons du mal à
décarboner je pense à l'aviation je
pense aux Maritimes je pense à
l'industrie lourde et donc un des enjeux
c'est quel gisement pour quel usage et
ça entre les deux c'est le chemin de la
planification qui a été balisé hier par
la première ministre et qui entre en
débat avec les parties prenantes
aujourd'hui pour allaiter pouvoir donner
les réponses aux questions que vous
posez merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
Breton pour le couplet républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre pourquoi
tant d'acharnement contre la filière de
l'élevage hier c'est la Cour des comptes
qui est dans un rapport sur les élevages
bovins à appeler à une réduction
importante du cheptel bovin dans notre
pays et pour la Cour des comptes cette
réduction devrait s'accompagner d'une
limitation de la consommation de viande
car je cite le rapport un tiers des
Français consomme davantage que le
plafond de 500 g de viande rouge par
semaine prévu par le Programme national
nutrition santé mais de quoi se mêlent
la Cour des comptes madame la Première
ministre nous aurions aimé vous entendre
ou entendent votre Ministre de
l'Agriculture remettre à leur place les
magistrats de la Cour des comptes leur
rôle n'est pas de dicter aux Français
leur mode d'alimentation ni de prescrire
la taille de nos élevages et nous
pouvons même nous demander si cette
attaque contre la filière viande n'est
pas organisée délibérément
la semaine dernière c'était en effet
votre ministre de l'économie et des
finances qui inaugurait en grande pompe
une usine spécialisée dans les
substituts végétaux à la viande à cette
occasion il assurait ouvertement la
promotion des protéines végétales tout
en cherchant à disqualifier les
protéines animales plus inquiétant
encore une indiquait que cette nouvelle
usine était je cite l'exemple parfait de
ce que nous voulons faire avec le projet
loi de loi industrielle alors madame la
Première ministre à quoi cela sert-il
d'aller au salon de l'agriculture
pendant de longues heures à la rencontre
de nos éleveurs si c'est pour mieux les
poignarder dans le dos quelques semaines
plus tard nos éleveurs se battent chaque
jour pour maintenir la viabilité de
leurs exploitations ils le font dans un
contexte économique compliqué et en
subissant des contraintes réglementaires
excessives ils ont besoin de tout notre
soutien madame la Première ministre
quand vont cesser ses attaques contre
l'évier l'élevage et contre
l'agriculture de notre pays
[Applaudissements]
urinistre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Xavier Breton d'abord
je vous prie d'excuser Marc féno retenus
au Sénat et Bruno Le Maire retenu par
ailleurs qui m'ont chargé l'un et
l'autre de répondre à votre question
l'un et l'autre soutiennent le secteur
de l'élevage et plus généralement
d'ailleurs l'agriculture française
depuis longtemps vous le savez Bruno Le
Maire a été en son temps ministre de
l'Agriculture il est désormais ministre
de l'économie il défendait l'agriculture
à l'époque il la défend encore
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement soutient
l'élevage français vous le savez vous ne
l'avez pas voté c'est dommage mais cette
majorité a voté deux lois pour soutenir
l'agriculture française également et
Gallim 2 qui ont mis en place
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
qui ont mis en place des plantes
filières ambitieux y compris pour la
filière de l'élevage à la fois en
accompagnant la montée en gamme parce
que nous vous déplaise la consommation
de viande aujourd'hui elle est en
diminution il faut moins de viande il
faut surtout mieux de viande et nous
accompagnons la filière dans cette
direction il faut aussi reconnaître la
captation de carbone faite dans les
prairies la protection de la
biodiversité faite par l'élevage dans
les montagnes et pour autant monsieur le
député je pense qu'il y a aucune raison
si je puis dire de se mettre la tête
dans le sable comme le font les
autruches le sac d'autruche est très bon
la politique de l'autruche elle n'est
pas bonne
aujourd'hui le développement de la
protéine végétale c'est une réalité moi
je souhaite que la France puisse être
aussi sur ce terrain là que des
industries françaises créent de l'emploi
en France y compris vous le savez pour
produire des protéines végétales qui
parfois d'ailleurs savent à nourrir
pardon nos animaux nous devons faire
l'un et l'autre nous ferons l'un et
l'autre sans caricature sans division et
j'espère que nous vous trouverons à vos
côtés à nos côtés pour défendre
réellement l'élevage française et son
développement y compris à
l'international c'est la France qui a
ouvert le marché chinois aux éleveurs
français c'est la fierté de cette
majorité c'est la fierté du président de
la République merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est un monsieur Christopher
weisberg pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre aux images de chaos qui ont
frappé barmut ont succédé les images
d'un camp uni où les pays du G7 et le
président Zelenski ont réaffirmé avec
force leur parfaite unité face à
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
depuis que cette guerre a commencé aux
portes de l'Europe il y a au moins une
autre d'espoir dans cette sinistre
partition les alliés du G7 ne sont
jamais apparus aussi sûr de leur unité
unis dans le soutien humanitaire que
l'Europe ne cesse d'apporter aux
Ukrainiens unis par un renforcement
inédit des capacités militaires
européennes et dans lequel la France
prend toute sa part comme en témoin de
le projet de loi de programmation
militaire que nous examinons cette
semaine Unis aussi dans les sanctions
que nous continuons d'infliger au régime
russe nous Européens en parfaite
coordination avec les États-Unis et les
membres du G7 dans le cadre de mon
rapport sur les sanctions
internationales j'étais à Bruxelles et à
Washington la semaine dernière et les
acteurs que nous avons audition ont
unanimement reconnu que jamais nos
régimes de sanctions n'avaient été aussi
bien coordonnées entre nos deux
continents cette unité entre les pays du
G7 elle s'arrête malheureusement aux
portes de cette hémicycle à l'extrême
droite d'abord le leader du
rassemblement national est passé d'une
servitude financière à Vladimir Poutine
à une connivence coupable tout aussi
grave en dénonçant gélatite des
sanctions économiques qui ne servent à
rien et à l'extrême gauche le leader des
insoumis nostalgiques de la guerre
froide se tient prêt à relancer son
projet d'alliance altermondialiste et
entretient par son obsession
anti-américaine un clivage nord-sud qui
pousse à la division et qui fait le
bonheur du Kremlin pourtant la réalité
que vous refusez de reconnaître c'est
que ces sanctions ont permis de frapper
durement l'effort de guerre russes aussi
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
détailler les nouvelles mesures
annoncées par l'Union européenne dans le
cas de ce 11ème paquet de sanctions
dédié notamment au contournement merci
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
weisberg
vous l'avez dit le soutien de la France
à l'Ukraine et sans faille et il sera
aussi longtemps que nécessaire la venue
du président Zelinski airoshima pour
présenter les vues de son pays non
seulement aux dirigeants du G7 mais
également aux dirigeants d'autres pays
comme l'Inde l'Indonésie ou le Brésil
par exemple on est l'illustration et je
souligne que ce geste est une source de
fierté pour la France autant qu'un geste
diplomatique
utile
vous l'avez dit l'unité du G7 est
précieuse mais je voudrais ajouter que
les principes que nous défendons la
souveraineté des États leur indépendance
leur intégrité territoriale sont des
principes universels ce sont ceux de la
Charte des Nations Unies et c'est
pourquoi plus de 140 états plus de 140
états et bien au-delà du G7 ont soutenu
à l'ONU chaque fois qu'il y a eu un vote
les résolutions demandant à la Russie de
cesser son agression
c'est dans ce cadre que la politique de
sanction trouve sa source il faut amener
la Russie à constater son échec et en
parallèle il faut lutter contre les
contournements
après 10 paquets et bientôt 11 adopté
par l'Union européenne l'effet de ses
sanctions est réelle
désorganisation de l'activité
industrielle notamment dans des secteurs
clés pour la défense baisse des recettes
budgétaires forte baisse des revenus
d'hydrocarbures et tout ceci entrave
l'effort de guerre russes et c'est bien
objectif et cet effort ne se député nous
le maintiendrons je le répète aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra car il est
indispensable à la paix juste et durable
que nous défendons et que tous ici dans
cette hémicycle devrait en effet
défendre je remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur David Topia pour le groupe
liote
merci Madame le présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
l'épidémie de grippe aviaire flamme à
nouveau dans le sud-ouest avec une
situation qui semble hors de contrôle
face un virus plus virulent que celui
détecté en janvier
au 17 mai 33 foyers étaient confirmés
dans le Gers doublant leur nombre à une
semaine
face à la déferlante les abattages de
foyer et les dépeuplements préventifs
ont repris au moment même où la filière
finissait tout juste de repeupler les
élevages de plein air
sur le terrain j'ai rencontré de
nombreux éleveurs en détresse
psychologique mais aussi financière leur
trésorerie sont en situation dramatique
du fait du nom du non-règlement du solde
de la crise précédente
c'était d'ailleurs le sujet de mon
intervention au gouvernement ici même il
y a trois mois
deux épisodes épidémie aussi rapprochés
appellent des mesures de soutien
renforcées mais surtout rapides à
destination de professionnels de
l'activité de dépend plus désormais que
d'autorisation administrative pour cela
il faut accéder le versement à 100% de
la VMO 2022 et s'inscrire dans la même
démarche pour les dossiers de ses débuts
d'années faire une remise à jour
immédiate des barèmes 2022 pour les 3e
et 4e trimestre qui ont largement minoré
l'impact financiers subis par les
producteurs en toute fin d'année
soutenir les professionnels avec la mise
en place d'une cellule auprès des
organismes bancaires pour les
accompagner négocier un geste
significatif à défaut d'une adblanches
pour les cotisations de la MSA des
professionnels impactés l'espoir des
éleveurs repose désormais sur la
stratégie de vaccination dont les
modalités restent encore trop floues
vous devez accélérer sa mise en place
sans attendre le ton prochain avec un
caractère obligatoire et une prise en
charge à 100% par l'État le gouvernement
doit agir rapidement en faveur d'une
filière qui refuse d'être la victime
collatérale de ce nouvel épisode de
grippe aviaire
Véran ministre délégué
gé du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés David topiaque j'excuse
l'absence du ministre de l'Agriculture
Marc féno il est actuellement au Sénat
Auban il est retenu il m'a demandé de
vous répondre ainsi qu'à votre collègue
du Gers Jean-René Cazeneuve qui avait
aussi sollicité les services du 200
ministère depuis 14 mars 2023 la
situation nationale regarde hautement
pathogène était assez ni aucun foyer
n'était enregistré depuis cette date
toutefois depuis le 4 mars depuis le 4
mai vous l'avez dit de nouveau foyer en
élevage sont apparus pratica
principalement de canard et
principalement dans votre département du
Gers et dans les Landes à date du 22 mai
67 foyers sont recensés sur la région
dont 48 dans le Gers je vais vous dire
que nous savons les difficultés qui
traversent nos éleveurs et la filière
cette résurgence de la grippe aviaire
dans le Sud-Ouest a déclenché une
réponse immédiate des services de l'État
en concertation avec les filières
professionnelles dès le premier foyer la
mobilisation a été totale pour mettre en
œuvre des mesures de gestion sanitaires
réglementaire comme dans de tels cas une
zone de protection de 3 km a été mise en
place autour de chaque foyer complété
d'une zone de surveillance dans un rayon
de 10 km les mesures de biosécurité le
recensement des élevages la surveillance
sanitaire sont par ailleurs renforcés
enfin un concertation avec les filières
professionnelles des mesures
complémentaires sont mises en œuvre dans
une zone réglementée supplémentaire dans
le rayon entre 10 et 20 km autour des
foyers afin de créer une barrière
sanitaire pour contenir la contamination
et permettre une détection précoce
d'éventuelles foyers grâce à la
surveillance active réalisée par des
dépistages réguliers dans tous les
élevages et dans tous les élevages le
respect des règles de biosécurité et
capitales vous le savez pour limiter le
risque d'introduction du virus et cette
résurgence du virus souligne l'intérêt
vous l'avez dit également de poursuivre
activement les travaux en vie de la mise
en place d'une stratégie de vaccination
avec pour objectif de la rendre
opérationnelle à l'automne prochain j'ai
pris note monsieur le député des
questions vous portiez que vous posiez
sur le soutien financier apporter à la
filière notamment les mesures fiscales
évidemment je vais les relayer au
ministre de l'Agriculture qui fera un
complément de réponse par écrit si vous
en êtes d'accord
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur Adrien Clouet pour
le groupe la France insoumise
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
samedi dernier France 2 invité à un
témoin de la violence sociale qui règne
dans le pays un de nos compatriotes qui
exposé ses grandes difficultés à nourrir
ses quatre enfants en achetant des
paquets de pâtes cet homme c'est
évidemment Bruno Le Maire qui s'est
livré un numéro d'indécence totalement
démagogique pour quelqu'un payer 10000
euros par mois et je ne compte pas le
droit d'auteur chez arlequin une chose
juste néanmoins il reconnaît ce que sa
politique orchestre à savoir le retour
des privations et de la fin de notre
pays et que faites-vous dans cette
situation et bien rien à part promouvoir
une réforme des retraites uniques et
scélérates car à chaque alerte vous
regardez ailleurs les prix de la
nourriture ont augmenté de 15%, vous
refusez de les bloquer mais vous êtes
disponible pour voler deux ans de vie
aux françaises et aux Français une
personne sur six ne mange pas à sa fin
dans le pays accorderez-vous aux
associations le milliard doit elles ont
besoin pour leur venir en aide non vous
êtes trop occupé à voler deux ans de vie
aux personnes la moitié de nos
compatriotes renonce à leurs courses ne
remplissent plus leurs vous êtes vous et
forcés d'organiser la hausse des
salaires non vous êtes pris sur une
réforme des retraites les jeunes sont de
plus en plus nombreux dans les files
d'attente associatifs pour recevoir
l'aide alimentaire avez-vous accordé le
repas à un euro au CROUS non vous étiez
occupé à nous imposer une réforme des
retraites les associations d'aide enfin
ont été ruinées par vos réformes
fiscales là où l'ISF permettait aux
supers riche de s'acheter un brin de
conscience une fois de temps en temps en
donnant de manière défiscalisée à ce
type d'association et bien désormais
elles ont elles éprouvent les
difficultés les plus vives à lever de
l'argent pourquoi parce que vous êtes
occupé exclusivement à voler deux ans de
vie aux françaises et aux Français bref
que fait Monsieur Bruno Le Maire et bien
il supplie devant le siège du Medef un
cierge à la main que certains veuillent
bien limiter leur marge personnelle mais
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
êtes au pouvoir donc s'il vous plaît
gouverner
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Geneviève Darius sec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député alors vous avez raison la hausse
des prix elle impacte les ménages les
plus fragiles c'est une réalité et
cette situation est la conséquence
directe bien sûr de l'inflation
alimentaire qui existe aujourd'hui et je
crois que face à ces difficultés le
gouvernement agit depuis l'été 2022
premièrement avec 46 milliards d'euros
dépensés par l'État pour contenir la
hausse des prix de l'énergie qui ont un
impact direct sur l'alimentation bien
entendu ce qui a permis de faire en
sorte que l'inflation soit parmi les
plus basses d'Europe avec la
revalorisation anticipée de 4% des
prestations complétées au 1er avril
pour porter l'augmentation à 5,6% par an
avec le trimestre anti-inflation que
porte actuellement Bruno Le Maire et et
Olivia Grégoire et avec en matière
d'alimentation une action double d'abord
le renforcement exceptionnel des moyens
des associations d'aide alimentaire les
crédits de l'État ont ainsi triplé
depuis 2022 et oui ah bon ils ont triplé
pour atteindre 156 millions d'euros
ce qui a permis d'affecter une urgence
en urgence 10 millions d'euros à l'aide
alimentaire à destination des étudiants
et d'apporter des réponses spécifiques
aux outre-mer enfin par ailleurs la
lutte du gouvernement contre la
précarité alimentaire se concrétise en
2023 par le déploiement du programme
mieux manger pour tous 60 millions
d'euros pour cette première année
d'amorçage qui va permettre de financer
des paniers et des chèques-verre et
solidaires et surtout d'améliorer la
qualité des produits distribués alors
oui nous agissons nous agissons avec
pragmatisme sur le terrain et pas par
des incantations comme vous le faites en
permanence
je vous remercie madame la ministre
cette seconde
merci beaucoup madame ministre j'ai
compté vous avez lu 11 fiches donc cet
avert très intéressant j'en retiens que
vous allez croiser les doigts en
espérant que les estomacs se remplissent
c'est dommage
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marc Tellier pour le
groupe GDR
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail dans le vacarme des
promesses politiques du gouvernement le
silence qui suit résonne plus fort dans
une énième un et allocution le président
Emmanuel Macron nous a invité à engager
un dialogue social et à bâtir un nouveau
pacte pour le travail alors comment
expliquer vous la répression
inacceptable qui se déroule actuellement
chez verbaudet les menaces de
licenciement pour lourdes les actes
d'intimidation les violences physiques
et les arrestations arbitraires se
multiplient alors que les salariés ne se
battent que pour une revalorisation
modeste de 150 euros par mois en
majorité des femmes les salariés de
Vertbaudet ont commencé leur carrière au
SMIC et la terminerons au SMIC est-ce
cela votre vision d'avenir pour les
travailleuses françaises une politique
qui maintient les salaires au plus bas
en particulier pour les femmes jusqu'à
épuisement nous rejetons fermement ce
projet de société les travailleurs ne
veulent ni de petits chèques de l'État
ni de prime d'activité versées par la
CAF pour simplement survivre ils veulent
un véritable salaire versé par leur
entreprise nous exprimons notre total
soutien au grévistes et aux délégués
syndical qui a été enlevé devant chez
lui devant son fils menacé et monastère
leur courage est immense et leur
détermination est forte tout comme
celles des milliers de travailleurs qui
luttent contre la réforme des retraites
pour une augmentation des salaires ou de
meilleures conditions de travail dans ce
contexte comment expliquer vous monsieur
le ministre le silence du gouvernement
et l'absence total de l'État dans ce
conflit socialement qui est une lutte
pour la justice sociale ne serait-il pas
tant de nommer un médiateur
je vous remercie
et Monsieur Olivier dupe du travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion merci
Madame merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Tellier l'État n'est
pas absent de ce conflit je l'ai dit
l'État est intervenu dès le début du
conflit puisque la grève a été
déclenchée le 20 mars un accord
majoritaire je pense que vous n'en
partez pas nécessairement les termes
mais il est majoritaire à 63 % a été
signé à la fin du mois de mars et l'État
est entré en médiation par
l'intermédiaire de la dette la direction
des concentrés les services partir du 9
avril cette médiation a permis d'aller
vers l'embauche d'une trentaine
d'intérimaires et ses embauches ont été
concrétisés le 1er mai d'autres éléments
d'autres contacts ont été pris et
favorisés soit par les services
déconcentrés soit par les services du
ministère soit par mon cabinet
directement et ce après un échange que
j'avais pu avoir avec votre collègue
Fabien Roussel cela a permis des
échanges entre la direction générale du
groupe Vertbaudet et la direction
nationale de la CGT cela s'est traduit
par la tenue d'une réunion hier matin
avec des propositions nouvelles de la
direction générale qui ne l'ont pas été
acceptées par le même syndicat la CGT
qui n'avait pas signé l'accord
majoritaire je souhaite évidemment que
le dialogue social puisse permettre la
fin du conflit et si le dialogue social
permet d'améliorer la situation
d'améliorer la situation de vie et les
conditions de vie des salariés dont vous
avez décrit pour beaucoup d'entre elles
les difficultés c'est une bonne chose
vous avez aussi évoqué les faits qui
seraient survenus à l'encontre d'un
délégué syndical il y a quelques jours
mais services comme les services de la
préfecture on fait toute l'empris toutes
les diligences pour essayer de
comprendre et de savoir ce qui s'est
passé le délégué syndical a été reçu
pour dire ce qui lui est arrivé par les
services de l'État il a été encouragé à
déposer plainte à l'heure où je vous
parle mais cela peut changer aucune
plainte n'a été déposée ce qui n'a pas
empêché le parquet dans son indépendance
d'ouvrir une enquête je ne sais pas et
ce n'est pas mon rôle de le faire
caractériser les faits et encore moins
les auteurs des violences que se
déléguer syndicat l'a subi ce qui
m'invite évidemment à dénoncer toute
forme de violence mais aussi à garder
une forme de prudence en attendant que
l'enquête puisse aboutir j'espère que
l'accord majoritaire intervenu pour être
complété par d'autres mesures et que
ainsi le conflit soit levé
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Didier Lemaire
pour le groupe horizon
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adressait à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
mais chers collègues j'associe à cette
question Laurent Marc Angeli président
du groupe d'amitié France Italie je
n'aime pas parler de la pluie et du beau
temps mais l'actualité m'y contrat
malheureusement il y a quelques semaines
je questionnais le gouvernement sur la
sécheresse hivernale que nous
traversions et je vous interroge
aujourd'hui sur les pluies diluviennes
déversées sur l'Italie ces derniers
jours l'équivalent de six mois de
précipitations tombés en quelques heures
seulement dans la région de l’emilie
romanes on y voit plus de 20 cours d'eau
qui était leur lit des grues boueuses
balayaient des villages entiers des
ponts s'effondrer 400 routes ça fait c
des glissements de terrain se creuser
humainement c'est plus de 10000
habitants contraints de quitter leur
domicile et malheureusement 14 personnes
décédées
l'ensemble de mes collègues horizons et
moi-même et j'en suis sûr l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale présentons
d'ailleurs toutes nos condoléances à nos
voisines et voisins européens la région
touchée par ces pluies diluviennes se
trouve à quelques kilomètres seulement
de la frontière entre nos deux pays et
pourtant très peu de médias relaient la
catastrophe naturelle humaine et
économique qui se passe en Italie comme
la France l'Italie est en stress
hydrique et l'eau tombait ces derniers
jours ne permettra pas de le résorber on
le sait le changement climatique dû à
l'activité humaine accroît l'intensité
la fréquence des phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes notre pays a
déjà vécu et vivra encore des
catastrophes similaires à ce sujet je
salue le travail et les annonces faites
par Monsieur le Ministre Christophe
Béchu
cependant j'aimerais savoir Monsieur le
Ministre si notre modèle de protection
des populations et de sécurité civile
mais aussi de préparation des
territoires répond à ces nouveaux enjeux
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sonia baquet secrétaire des tâches
chargée de la citoyenneté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
le maire vous nous interrogez sur
l'action de soutien à la France aux
suite aux inondations survenues au nord
de l'Italie les inondations en
emily-romagne au nord de l'Italie ont
fait 14 morts et entraîner l'évacuation
de plus de 36000 personnes face à ce
bilan dramatique la France a souhaité
au-delà des messes de soutien être
pleinement solidaires et à proposer dès
samedi l'engagement des moyens de
secours si l'Italie n'a pas dans un
premier temps souhaitait faire appel à
l'aide internationale les moyens de
secours propres sauvetage et à la mise
en sécurité des populations étant
suffisant les Italiens ont sollicité
hier l'aide européenne pour conforter
leurs moyens de pompage lourds la France
a donc fait partie en fin de matinée un
groupe lourd composé de moyens de
pompage d'une capacité de 5400 mètres
cubes heure et armé par 40 personnels
des formations militaires de sécurité
civile leur engagement est pour
l'instant prévu pour trois semaines
sur le territoire national puisque c'est
votre question les actions en cas
d'inondation seront dirigées par les
préfets des départements qui
s'appuieront essentiellement sur les
services d'incendiés de secours et sur
les moyens de la sécurité civile les
formations militaires comme les
hélicoptères de sauvetage les services
d'incendie et de secours disposent de
moyens adaptés aux risques qu'ils
couvrent ils disposent en particulier de
6325 personnels formés au sauvetage en
eaux vives et équipées pour affronter
les situations particulièrement à risque
dans le cadre de la solidarité nationale
le préfet peut faire appel aux autres
services d'incendiés de secours ainsi
qu'aux personnels militaires et de
sécurité civile ces engagements de
renfort financés par l'État sont
coordonnées au niveau zonal voire
nationale en fonction des situations les
37 hélicoptères de la sécurité civile
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
national sont également à disposition
pour effectuer des actions de sauvetage
ou mettre en sécurité les populations
placées dans des endroits inaccessibles
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la ministre
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse c'est nous savons que la
sécurité civile sera incontournable dans
les prochaines années et les
indispensable dans notre pays sur le
territoire national que l'ensemble des
élus et des citoyens citoyens prennent
part à ces enjeux je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur romain bobri
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur papendji ministre
de l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre notre école publique va mal
mais vous la fragilisez davantage encore
dans les territoires ruraux ces
territoires symboles de l'abandon de
l'État avec la disparition de l'ensemble
de ces services publics continuent à
être le paillasson de la politique du
gouvernement à la rentrée prochaine de
nombreuses fermetures de classe seront
mises en oeuvre comme c'est le cas dans
certaines communes de ma circonscription
et notamment dans le village des Ragues
ici comme ailleurs les effectifs seront
pourtant à la hausse à la rentrée
prochaine mais cette décision de
fermeture viendra surcharger les
effectifs et obligera à créer des
classes à double niveau créant un
casse-tête d'organisation
l'efficacité des effectifs réduit n'est
plus approuvés mais les écoles de nos
villages n'ont pas bénéficié du
dédoublement des classes pour permettre
aux enfants un meilleur apprentissage
des fondamentaux et malgré cela vous
continuez de creuser les inégalités bien
souvent ces écoles ont créé des classes
sulisses afin de permettre l'inclusion
au mieux des élèves souffrant de divers
troubles mais vous allez fragiliser
davantage lorsque la scolarité en les
répartissant dans des classes
surchargées et des par des
accompagnements des accompagnants pardon
d'élèves en situation de handicap
exerçant un métier en précarité et son
statut réduire le nombre d'écoles et de
classe c'est réduire également les
chances de succès de nos jeunes
générations car les Français ne mettent
pas tous leurs enfants dans les dans le
privé monsieur le ministre et nous
sommes nombreux à vouloir encore croire
en notre école publique il y a quelques
semaines la première ministre annonçait
un changement de méthode au sujet de ces
fermetures de classe en zone rurale
outre les effets d'annonce un jour il
faudra passer aux actes monsieur le
ministre les enfants de nos villages
doivent avoir les mêmes chances de
réussite que comptez-vous faire pour
mettre fin à ces inégalités
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
pop and dye ministre de la jeunesse et
de l'éducation nationale
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés bobry votre département des
Bouches-du-Rhône comme malheureusement
de nombreux autres départements va
connaître une baisse des effectifs
scolaires à la rentrée moins 1500 élèves
pour ceux qui le concerne dans votre
circonscription à elle seule ce sont
252 élèves dans le premier degré que
l'on va compter en moins si l'on avait
appliqué une règle purement arithmétique
ce sont donc 10 classes que nous aurions
fermées dans votre circonscription or
nous enfermons que deux d'un côté pour
pour en ouvrir deux autres dans deux
communes qui connaissent une croissance
de leurs effectifs scolaires en
l'occurrence les communes d'Alain et
d'Orgon pour ce qui concerne les Bouches
du Rhône plus généralement à la dotation
initiale nous venons d'ajouter 22 postes
de professeurs des écoles de manière à
améliorer le taux d'encadrement qui va
s'améliorer donc dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône puisqu'il va passer de
23,2 élèves par classe à 22,3 élèves par
classe dans les semaines à venir en
fonction aussi des remontées des élus de
terrain bien entendu nous allons
procéder à d'ultime ajustements de
manière à ce que la situation soit
stabilisée pour la rentrée à venir
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mon cher collègue allez-y monsieur le
ministre nouveau chiffre ne sont pas
bons il y a bien plus que deux
fermetures de classe sur ma
circonscription et dans cette école les
effectifs à la rentrée prochaine sont
déjà prévus à la hausse et malgré tout
vous continuez à vouloir fermer une des
classes je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député vous êtes
entretenu avec la directrice académique
des services de l'éducation nationale la
semaine dernière je l'ai eu où il y a
quelques jours j'ai lu au téléphone
c'est elle qui m'a communiqué les
chiffres que je vous donne nous pouvons
vous les préciser si vous le souhaitez
bien entendu nous sommes à l'écoute des
élus mais nous devons aussi tenir compte
d'une réalité c'est la baisse accélérée
des effectifs scolaires partout en
France - 80 000 élèves à la rentrée
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Fatiha qui pour le
groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adressait à madame la Première
ministre mais je vois qu'elle s'est
absentée donc je vais poser une question
à tous les ministres qui restent au banc
où est passé votre projet de loi visant
à inscrire l'avortement le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution
le 24 novembre l'Assemblée nationale a
voté pour cette grande avancée pour le
droit des femmes le premier février
c'était au tour du Sénat le 8 mars en
fin le président de la République
annoncé un projet de loi constitutionnel
dans les prochains mois pour inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution et
puis et puis rien rien dans votre
feuille de route des 100 jours des 100
prochains jours dévoiler le 26 avril
dernier rien dans les discours télévisés
du président de la République qui
appelait à l'apaisement mais nous
parlementaires féministe n'avons pas
oublié cette promesse vous voulez
apaiser commencez par tenir vos
engagements
80% des Françaises et des Français
attendent sa transcription dans la
Constitution le droit des femmes n'est
pas un jeu ce n'est pas un slogan
politique et encore moins un prétexte
pour faire des promesses lâcher
opportunément un 8 mars
est bien trop important pour noyer dans
une révision constitutionnelle
fourre-tout nous attendons toutes et
tous votre projet de loi la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG doit en
être le seul objet vous le savez le
véhicule législatif le plus efficace
pour modifier la constitution reste un
projet de loi qui serait soumis au
Parlement réuni en Congrès les
parlementaires vous ont déjà démontré
qu'ils le voteraient c'est désormais à
votre tour de prendre vos
responsabilités
vous semblez avoir des calendriers pour
tous les sujets la case du lycée
professionnel la stigmatisation des plus
précaires et la diabolisation des
étrangers alors mes chers ministres où
en est le projet de loi pour faire
entrer le droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
madame madame la députée la réponse va
être brève car elle est dans la question
oui naturellement
vous avez dit madame la députée que le
Président de la République avait dit
dans les mois à venir et vous avez
rappelé d'ailleurs qu'il avait dit ça le
8 mars
avril mais voilà ne soyez pas impatiente
ça arrive
merci Monsieur le
minita madame Caroline yadan pour le
groupe Renaissance
je vous remercie
madame la Présidente cette question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale
monsieur le ministre la connaissance et
l'éducation permettent l'expression de
la liberté dans une démocratie en
transmettant leur savoir et en
valorisant les compétences des élèves
les enseignants participent à la
construction de notre société ils
permettent à nos enfants de préparer
leur avenir la revalorisation des
salaires du corps enseignant que vous
avez annoncé monsieur le ministre et
l'expression concrète de cette juste
reconnaissance
garant des valeurs de la République qui
nous unissent nos professeurs sont
depuis plusieurs années en première
ligne quand la laïcité est attaquée une
enquête publiée le 8 mars dernier par le
SNPDEN ça a révélé qu'un tiers des
personnels de direction confrontés à des
atteintes à la laïcité ne faisait pas
remonter ces signalements
c'est pour répondre à cette urgence
républicaine et aux demandes des
enseignants que le Conseil des Sages de
la laïcité a été créé en 2018 en
exerçant pour l'éducation nationale une
mission de conseil d'expertise et
d'études relatives à la mise en œuvre du
principe de laïcité c'est dans ce
contexte que vous avez annoncé le 14
avril dernier la nomination de 5
nouveaux membres au sein du conseil des
sages et avait promulgué un arrêté
modifiant son fonctionnement et
réduisant son autonomie parmi les
nouvelles nominations figurent celles
d'Alain policare dont certains propos
ont suscité des inquiétudes quand il a
précisé notamment ne pas défendre je
cite la dimension émotion émancipatrice
de la laïcité qui consiste à imposer la
lumière et lui préférer sa dimension
anglo-saxonne la ligne du président de
la République et de notre majorité
éclaire faire bénéficier à chacun de nos
enfants de la force du principe de
laïcité et de l'universalisme
républicain monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous dès lors nous indiquer votre
feuille de route en la matière je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur papenda le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Adam comme vous le savez sans doute
c'est moi qui est demandé à ce que une
publication des chiffres mensuels des
atteintes à laïcité soit faite c'est ce
que nous faisons moi après moi depuis le
mois de septembre et les chiffres sont
affichés sur le site du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est moi
également en accord avec la première
ministre et le président de la
République qui est souhaité là où c'est
nécessaire renforcer les équipes valeurs
de la République nous les avons renforcé
c'est aujourd'hui plus de 650 personnes
à travers tout le territoire qui
réponde aux sollicitations qui forment
également les personnels nous avons
accentué la formation des personnels
plus de 5000 chefs d'établissement et
leurs adjoints ont été formés depuis le
mois de novembre y compris à propos des
remontées car en effet il faut faire rem
les atteintes à la laïcité et je peux
vous dire que nous progressions en la
matière particulièrement depuis le mois
de janvier c'est moi qui est renforcé
les mesures disciplinaires en cas
d'atteinte à la laïcité en diffusant des
circulaires très clairs auprès des chefs
d'établissements c'est nous qui avons
aussi au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale institutionnalisé le Conseil
des Sages de la laïcité et des valeurs
de la République en lui donnant une
assise juridique qu'il n'avait pas
jusqu'à présent en confirmant ses
membres y compris la présidence et en
confirmant les principes même qui
régissent l'action et le travail de ce
conseil très précieux et avec qui
j'échange régulièrement donc madame la
députée vous m'appelez à réaffirmer cet
engagement sans faille je le fais
volontiers en rappelant et c'est ça ce
sur quoi je voudrais insister que le
principe de laïcité c'est pas seulement
une crainte c'est pas seulement une
sanction la laïcité doit aussi être
appréciée elle doit être aimée comme le
disait Jean Jaurès la République doit
être laïque et sociale elle ne sera
laïque que lorsqu'elle aura su être
social je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Madame Sabrina c'est
bailli pour le groupe écologiste merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adressait au ministre de
l'intérieur mais je vois qu'il n'est
plus là donc je vais quand même la poser
madame la ministre j'ai écouté avec
consternation votre réponse à mon
collègue François pickman concernant le
fichage des élèves musulmans le jour de
l'Aïd car encore une fois vous répondez
à côté comme votre tweet d'hier nous
vous posons la question clairement
avez-vous ciblé les élèves musulmans le
21 avril dernier et vous répondez
complètement à côté en donnant l'exemple
du suivi de procession religieuse ou de
la messe le dimanche dans l'espace
public alors que l'on vous parle de
l'école vous permettez même de vous
défausser sur les majorités précédentes
et vous bredouillez que oui la demande a
peut-être été formulée de manière
maladroite ce qui est grave madame la
ministre c'est qu'avant que certains ne
sonnent l'alerte vous n'ayez rien vu de
grave dans ces pratiques indignes de
notre pays
pourquoi alors même que vous prétendez
que cette demande avait pour but un
simple suivi du déroulement des fêtes
religieuses dans la sphère publique les
services de l'éducation nationale et du
rectorat se désolidarise et affirme ne
pas avoir été informé en amont de cette
décision la réalité c'est que demander
un rapport sur l'absentéisme le jour de
l'Aïd c'est cibler les élèves musulmans
pour leur pratique religieuses la
réalité madame la ministre c'est que le
gouvernement a franchi la ligne rouge
madame la ministre nous vous reposons
solennellement la question sur l'école
pas sur les messes le dimanche ni sur
les processions religieuses dans la rue
les services du ministère de l'Intérieur
ont-ils fait la demande le 21 avril jour
de l'Aïd d'un bilan sur l'absentéisme
des élèves si tel est le cas nous
demandons à la première ministre
d'offrir des garanties à la représentant
nationale pour que ces pratiques ne se
reproduisent plus jamais dans notre pays
je vous remercie je vous remercie ma
chère collègues la parole est à Madame
Sonia bac S secrétaire d'État en charge
de la citoyenneté merci madame la
Présidente mes et Messieurs les Députés
madame la députée sebahi d'abord je le
répète il n'y a aucun fichage des élèves
dans l'école de la République en
fonction de leur appartenance religieuse
ne vous en déplaise et je le répète
également c'est le travail de nos
services de renseignement de suivre les
grandes fers les grandes fêtes
religieuses dans la sphère publique le
ramadan concerne une part importante de
nos concitoyens c'est aujourd'hui un
fait sociétal qu'il nous appartient de
suivre y compris à l'école et donc je
vous demande d'arrêter de faire des
raccourcis sans fondement quand nos
services suivent la fête des lumières
pour la communauté juive ils ne sont pas
antisémites par plus qu'ils ne sont
quand ils suivent le ramadan islamophobe
et c'est indigne de penser le contraire
je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Nathalie date
qu'on s'est au Carvalho pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics monsieur
le ministre vous avez introduit une
nouvelle obligation déclarative à la
charge des propriétaires de locaux
d'habitation en effet la loi de finances
pour 2020 qui a supprimé à compter de
2023 la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences principales à institué cette
nouvelle obligation déclarative
codifiée à l'article 1418 du Code
Général des Impôts elle doit être
accomplie pour la première fois avant le
1er juillet 2023 cependant la
déclaration doit être souscrite par voie
électronique l'administration indique
même qu'elle s'effectue depuis le
service en ligne gérer mes biens
immobiliers à partir de l'espace
sécurisé du site impop.gouv.fr
malheureusement l'administration n'a pas
prévu de formulaire de déclaration
papier de type CERFA or de nombreux
propriétaires ne disposent pas d'une
résidence principale équipée d'un accès
à Internet tandis que d'autres indiquent
ne pas en être ne pas être en mesure de
souscrire la déclaration par voie
électronique aussi et compte tenu
qu'être obligé de se déplacer dans un
centre des impôts ne serait constitué
une option puisqu'il est de plus en plus
difficile d'avoir quelqu'un au téléphone
pour prendre rendez-vous ou obtenir un
renseignement et que faire la queue
pendant des heures pour que quelqu'un
pour quelqu'un qui travaille n'est pas
envisageable pourriez-vous mettre à
disposition des Français un formulaire
CERFA de déclaration afin que nos
concitoyens puissent l'envoyer par la
poste au Trésor public et est-il prévu
d'adresser un courrier papier aux
personnes dépourvues d'Internet et ne
sachant s'en servir dans la mesure où
cette information n'a jusqu'à présent
pas été large ment diffusé
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre chargé
des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
vous avez raison et vous l'avez rappelé
il y a une déclaration d'occupation du
logement que doivent réaliser les
propriétaires c'est à la suite de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
puisque l'administration fiscale doit
pouvoir connaître le statut des biens
immobiliers pour une raison simple ou
plutôt pour deux raisons simples il
reste une taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires et on ne veut pas
appliquer une taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires à ce qui serait
en fait une résidence principale et par
ailleurs on veut que les communes qui
veulent procéder à une taxation sur les
résidences d'une taxe d'habitation sur
les résidence secondaire et même
l'augmenter puisque le Parlement l'a
permis dans son vote qu'elle puisse le
faire et donc il faut bien identifier
quels sont les résidences principales
quelles sont les résidences secondaires
et quel est le statuts d'occupation du
logement une fois qu'on a dit ça il y a
une procédure dématérialisée qui a été
mise en place je veux assister sur un
point puisque c'est pas toujours clair
pour les contribuables ce qui doit être
réalisé avant le 1er juillet ça n'est
pas l'intégralité des informations qui
sont demander sur la plateforme dont
certaines sont facultatives c'est
simplement le statut du logement est-ce
qu'il est occupé ou pas est-ce que c'est
une résidence principale résidence
secondaire est-ce qu'il y a un locataire
et si oui qui est ce locataire ce sont
les informations qu'il faut demander je
le dis qu'il faut donner je le dis
puisque parfois certains contribuables
ont pu être
perplexe devant la présentation
cadastrale de l'horlogements se sont
posés beaucoup de questions mais tous
ces sujets là évidemment peuvent être
validées plus tard ensuite vous avez
raison il faut être capable
d'accompagner les contribuables qui en
ont besoin sur les 340 000 mails qui ont
été reçus par la direction générale des
finances publiques 75% déjà une réponse
000 appels ont eu lieu sur ce sujet et
sur 280 000 appels 123000 déclarations
ont été réalisées par les agents de la
DG FIP et j'insiste sur ce point quant à
contribuable n'a pas accès à internet
qu'il ne sait pas réalisé sa déclaration
on peut la réaliser pour lui dans un
centre des finances publiques ou par
téléphone ça a été fait pour plus de 100
000 contribuables vous demandez si un
formulaire papier peut être remis en
place ça fait partie des pistes que je
m'engage à examiner notre objectif vous
l'avez compris c'est évidemment
d'accompagner les contribuables et
évidemment que personne de bonne foi ne
sera pénalisé dans cette opération merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre madame la
députée non la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue